So, das ist immer.
Und mein Headset ist komplett verknotet.
Wie geht das eigentlich immer?
Wie schaffen es Kabel, die einfach nur rumliegen, sich zu verknoten?
Das geht doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Naja, ist halt verknotet, ich meine, okay.
Also, Leute, ich habe übrigens gestern noch was rausgekriegt.
Und zwar habe ich mich doch darüber beschwert,
dass in Visual Studio auf meinem Main-Account,
also nicht auf meinem Streaming-Windows-Account,
dass das so langsam ist.
Und ich habe festgestellt,
die Geschwindigkeit von Visual Studio,
beziehungsweise die Autocompletion in Visual Studio ist,
jetzt haltet euch fest,
hängt direkt damit zusammen, wie viele Desktop-Icons man hat.
Ist jetzt kein Witz?
Es ist echt kein Witz?
Auf meinem Haupt-Account habe ich quasi so viele Sachen auf dem Desktop,
dass es komplett voll.
Ja, ich benutze meinen Desktop eigentlich so,
als, als, als, keine Ahnung, wo alles hingeht,
bis ich irgendwann mal, ja, echt jetzt.
Ähm, wir können das mal ausprobieren.
Wir können das mal, wir probieren das mal, wir probieren das mal aus.
Äh, wir probieren das mal aus.
Also.
Pass mal auf, wir machen jetzt einfach mal irgendwie.
Wir probieren das mal aus.
Also.
Ich mache jetzt einfach das, was ich jetzt mache.
Ich mache das mal von gestern auf.
Wir programmieren jetzt nichts.
Aber ich zeige euch mal einfach, wie schnell das hier ist.
So.
Pass mal auf.
Guck mal, wenn ihr das hier.
So.
Fuck.
Jetzt.
Hallo?
Mein Backspace geht nicht.
Backspace geht nicht.
What the fuck?
Zumindest.
Hier ist relativ, hier läuft es jetzt relativ gut.
Und auch die neuen Sachen, die auf Porten so ein Netz machen,
was machen wir mal in Desktop voll und jetzt passt mal auf.
Mit was machen wir den Desktop voll?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es egal ist,
mit was man den Desktop voll macht oder ob man,
weil ich hatte zum größten Teil Audioaufnahmen drauf.
Okay, ich dupliziere jetzt einfach mal das Bild von meiner Katze.
Schwarz, war ab.
Kopiert einfach das.
Alter, wenn das nicht.
Kopiert einfach mal das Bild von meiner Katze dahin.
Guck mal.
Mal gucken wir uns das an.
Man sieht schon, wie laggy der Ordner wird, ne?
Warum sowas überhaupt
lag verursacht, ist schon...
Seht ihr, wie sehr das rumlaggt, Alter?
Ich hab einfach nur ein paar Dateien
kopiert.
Guck mal, das ist übelst...
Sogar die Darstellung im Explorer ist übelst am laggen.
Oh,
der Explorer reagiert nicht mehr.
Wegen ein paar
Desktop-Items.
Und ich hatte da wirklich...
Guckt euch das mal an, der macht nichts mehr.
Der ist komplett rip.
Der Explorer, wegen ein paar Desktop-Icons hier.
Seht ihr das?
Das ist mega fake.
Und ich hatte noch viel mehr drauf, ne?
Das reicht immer noch nicht.
Das reicht noch nicht,
weil ich hatte viel mehr auf meinem Desktop.
Da hat sich zwei Jahre Audioaufnahmen,
zwei Jahre Download, alles angesammelt
auf meinem Desktop. Also ich hatte wahrscheinlich so
2000 Dinge auf dem Desktop oder so.
Guckt euch das mal an, jetzt hab ich
das kopiert, jetzt geht schon mal gar nichts mehr.
Boah,
Kripp.
Desktop-Icons, der Performance-Killer
unter Windows Nummer 1.
Das sind 762
Stück. Ja und, was sind
762?
So,
noch einmal einfügen.
Was sind 762 Dateien? Das ist nix.
Hast du
irgendein Desktop-Sync-Zeugs an? Nö.
Ich hab einen Nextcloud-Ordner,
den ich syncen könnte. Da ist aber bloß Notizen
und ein bisschen Kram drin.
So, okay.
Ich hab meinen Desktop vollgemacht.
Warum macht man das? Weil der Desktop
die beste Ablage ist für alles.
So, und jetzt machen wir mal Whistle Studio auf.
Jetzt passt mal auf. Und jetzt ist wahrscheinlich...
...
...hoffe ich, dass mein Backspace wieder funktioniert.
Das falsche
Whistle Studio ist das übrigens.
War nur 2019 betroffen, lustigerweise.
Wo ist denn der Rest
von meinem Startmenü?
Darf ich jetzt wieder Backspace drücken?
Ja! Guck mal!
Jetzt laggt's übelst!
Naja, wobei...
Ah, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das was damit zu tun hat.
Doch! Guck mal! Ah, Moment, mein Backspace...
Sag mal, warum ist in Whistle Studio
mein Backspace kaputt?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Hallo? Warum geht
Backspace nicht mehr?
Ist ja total hängengeblieben.
Mein Backspace ist kaputt.
Aber Backspace hier funktioniert?
Fuck, Alter.
Geht Backspace in
2017?
Warum ist mein Backspace in Whistle Studio
kaputt?
WTF? Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das möglich ist.
Backspace not working.
I used to close the files
then close and reopen the...
Was?
Alt-Enter?
What?
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Aber...
Manche Windows-Geschichten
sind schon echt hardcore kaputt.
Alt-Enter bringt nichts.
Wenn man Solutions öffnet,
wo Ordner auf sind.
Kann ich mir eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen,
dass das was damit zu tun hat.
Übrigens, der Explorer ist auch
mega langsam, wenn man
so viele Desktop-Bilder hat.
Also das scheint komplett...
Guckt euch das mal an!
Wo ist das Problem? Ich meine, okay, das sind
750 Sachen auf dem Desktop.
750 Sachen auf dem Desktop,
das hat man normalerweise nicht.
Aber das ist auch nicht annähernd
die Menge, wo ich sagen würde,
das sollte Probleme machen.
Hier funktioniert Backspace.
Guckt, hier funktioniert Backspace.
Oh nein, Lizenz-Key teilweise liegt.
Aber nicht alles.
Den kann man damit nichts anfangen.
Backspace ist kaputt!
What the fuck, Microsoft?
Was ist denn hier wieder los?
Okay, kein Bock jetzt.
Ich lösche jetzt erstmal vom Desktop.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob Backspace wieder geht,
wenn ich alle Bilder von der Katze
vom Desktop lösche?
Okay, jetzt ist der Desktop wieder
ein bisschen leerer.
Erstmal alles löschen.
Wer da löscht?
Machen wir mal was anderes auf.
Ne, der Backspace ist kaputt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Ich meine, hallo,
sogar in Notepad geht
man Backspace.
Warum?
Was? Okay.
Warum sollte sich das resetten?
Okay.
Tools, Options,
Environments.
Ich will, dass mein Backspace wieder funktioniert.
Tools, Options,
Environment,
Keyboard,
Reset.
Yes.
Geht wieder.
Funktioniert wieder. Backspace ist wieder da.
Muschel Studio hat einfach mal mein Backspace
gelöscht. Einfach so, weil
es geht.
Einfach weil es gedacht hat, das ist eine gute Idee.
Wir löschen jetzt,
dass der Max Text löschen kann.
Es kann doch mal passieren.
Hardware,
was? Ne, hat mit Hardware-Tool
nichts zu tun. Ich glaube nicht, dass das
Hardware-Tool etwas damit zu tun hat,
dass mein Backspace nicht mehr funktioniert.
Das wär's jetzt.
So advancede GUI-Technologie
von vor 20 Jahren, dass der Backspace kaputt ist.
Es gibt eh so viele Sachen, die mir an Windows
auf den Keks gehen.
Das ist ein gutes,
gutes Stichwort.
Zwar habe ich ein Video
gefunden, und zwar von einem ehemaligen
Microsoft-Mitarbeiter.
Arbeitet ihr agil
bei euch?
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Wir sagen gerne, dass wir agil arbeiten, ohne agil zu arbeiten.
Also ihr kennt das ja wahrscheinlich.
Also es kennt wahrscheinlich jeder,
der bei einem bisschen größeren
Laden arbeitet, das immer relativ
viel gesagt wird, und
dann
es dann anders gemacht wird.
Also
ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es bei allen größeren Sachen
so ist. Zumindest bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber und bei dem
davor ist das so. Da wird immer ganz viel erzählt,
wenn der Tag lang ist, und nach dem Motto, oh, wir müssen
jetzt hier agiler werden, und ah, wir müssen jetzt hier das,
und wir müssen jetzt hier jenes, und
da guckst du dich schon an und denkst dir, okay,
das müssen wir jetzt genauso wie die letzten 30 Mal
vorher.
Und irgendwann, ein halbes Jahr später, hörst du nichts mehr von.
Ja, ich mache nochmal einen Hardware-Tool,
den Stream, wenn das Tool fertig ist.
Aber ich muss erstmal,
ich muss das jetzt erstmal in Ruhe fertig machen.
Kauft ihr das neue COD?
Ich krieg das hoffentlich gesponsert.
Bist du ein Ehrenmann?
Nein, ich bin ein Big Brain-Mann.
Macht dir
deine Arbeit Spaß? Zum größten Teil schon.
Ich meine, du hast
immer ein paar Dinger,
du hast immer ein paar Dinger, die nerven,
das hast du überall.
Aber an sich ist es ganz okay.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so,
dass ich sagen würde, ich muss jetzt unbedingt woanders hin.
Ich guck natürlich immer mal ab und zu ein bisschen,
was es so an Stellenanzeigen
gibt.
Einfach um zu schauen, was Sache ist.
Zumal ich jetzt ja auch nicht mehr
wirklich gebunden bin in Form von,
dass ich irgendwas verlieren würde.
Ich hab euch ja erzählt,
ich hab
einen Teil von dieser betrieblichen
Altersvorsorge abgeschlossen, da musst du halt
eine Weile dabei bleiben, dass es dann
nicht mehr verfallen kann. Aber das ist mittlerweile schon
nicht mehr verfallbar.
Deswegen will ich das da auch nicht
dran widmen. Aber ich hab jetzt nicht so großartiges
Interesse, woanders hinzugehen. Ich meine, es sei denn,
es kommt natürlich ein übertrieben geiles
Angebot in der übertrieben geilen Firma und so.
Aber selbst da muss man immer sagen,
ähm,
das Gras ist auf der anderen Seite ja immer grüner.
Also vieles sieht
von außen geil aus und ist es da nicht.
Und was ich halt richtig beknackt finde,
das, ähm,
was ich so richtig beknackt finde, sind diese
ganzen Werbevideos
von unterschiedlichen Unternehmen.
Also, Working at,
äh, was hat man da hier?
Working at,
keine Ahnung, war das Netflix?
Genau.
Und dann siehst du da so Sachen,
und da war das Working at
über, ähm,
ich hab von einem dieser
komischen Videos gesehen, also
wo sie zeigen, wie geil sie sind.
Und ich hab
das geguckt und hab mir gedacht, okay,
das hat niemand, der
wirklich in der IT arbeitet,
äh, auf Plausibilität
gecheckt, ja.
Das war so ein Werbevideo, wo sie
dann irgendeine Programmiererin hatten,
wo es, ich will nicht ausschließen, dass es dort auch
Programmiererinnen gibt, aber man muss halt sagen,
also vor allem IT und
90% sind Typen.
Ähm,
aber okay, ich mein, kann man ja
ein Video drüber machen, aber was sie dann da gezeigt haben,
ich muss mal gucken, ob ich dieses Video finde.
Das war Working at,
ich weiß nicht, ob es Working at Netflix,
Working at Über,
oder Working at, irgendwie
Software Engineer, oder was?
Amazon?
Aber das war auf jeden Fall mit irgendeiner
Asiatin, das weiß ich noch.
Ha. Zumindest haben sie in dem Video
erzählt, so nach dem Motto,
ja,
First Edition.
Das ist das Video,
aber nicht von ihm, wobei
den guck ich ab und zu auch noch ganz gern, sondern
gucken wir mal, ob er die Videos verlinkt hat.
Das Video ist da dabei.
Wo sie dann gezeigt,
genau, genau, dieses Video
meine ich. Was ist das denn?
Working at?
Das ist total, total, total
weltfremd. Was für ein Video
guckt der denn da? Ich mein, das ist übrigens
ein Video, wie man in der IT arbeitet, ne?
Ähm, wobei,
wir können uns das Video eigentlich angucken,
der macht echt ganz coole Videos. Zumindest, ähm,
in dem eigentlichen Video, wo es da drum ging,
ähm, haben sie halt
so gezeigt, nach dem Motto, ja, okay,
so toll ist es, bei uns zu arbeiten.
A day in the life of a
software engineer. Das ist es aber, glaube ich, nicht.
Google? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Zumindest war das, das da!
At Airbnb!
Genau, das da! Das ist so
richtig krass realitätsfremd.
Warte mal, das ist so krass realitätsfremd,
ey. Also, ich mein, erstens,
die meisten Leute stehen gar nicht, also, ich
zumindest, stehe nicht auf, wenn es hell ist, aber okay,
das kann ja auch im Sommer sein.
Das ist so realitätsfern.
Okay, na gut. Bis dahin,
ja, das passt ja noch, das ist ja halt nicht
jobabhängig.
Vor allem diese, diese super fröhliche
Musik morgens, das ist ja auch immer so
eine Sache, niemand, niemand
steht morgens auf, so
ich geh jetzt arbeiten, yeah,
du hast es geil,
ich darf jetzt arbeiten.
Weißt du, kein Mensch macht das.
Das ist unglaublich beknackt, aber
in den Videos tun sie immer so,
als freuen sich alle so wahnsinnig da
hinzugehen.
Das Pfeifen muss nochmal über, ich kann jetzt nicht pfeifen, weil das
übertrieben laut ist, wenn ich euch ins Ohr pfeife.
Doch, ich, ja.
Genau. Ihr müsst mal,
achtet mal in dem Video drauf,
wie, wie viel sie wirklich arbeitet.
Ihr müsst mal drauf achten,
wie viel sie wirklich arbeitet von ihrem
Arbeitstag. Also,
allein schon diese Open-Workspace-Geschichte geht mir
mega auf den Sack. Also, ich hab ja schon
bei uns, äh, Bedenken, was
Großraumbüros angeht, aber wir gucken jetzt erstmal weiter.
Wie sie sich freuen.
Jawoll, erstmal schon.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz cool, wenn's da Frühstück gibt.
Warum nicht?
Gut, ich mein.
Erstmal auf die Arbeit, ne Runde futtern,
E-Mails checken, das ist ja nicht verkehrt, ja.
Watertime,
was auch immer.
Was, ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Cornflakes
oder so. Also, sie ist jetzt
schon fast ne Stunde auf der Arbeit und hat noch nix.
Oh, oh, sie arbeitet. Sie arbeitet.
8.45 Uhr, merkt euch das. Sie wird nicht mehr so oft
vorkommen im Video.
Dann mal ne Runde stehen,
mal ne Runde Kaffee trinken zusammen, ja.
Oh, guck mal, da wird nochmal
gearbeitet. Okay. Äh,
Spoiler, ich glaube, das war's jetzt, wo sie gearbeitet
hat den ganzen Tag. Also von 8.30 Uhr
bis 10 und von 11 bis 12
oder so. Was gucken wir?
Wir gucken, wie, wie realistisch
diese Videos
sind. So, da geht erstmal
ne Runde futtern.
Muscheln, Alter.
So, da wird ne Runde was auch immer
gemacht.
Erstmal ne Runde abgechillsort.
Erstmal ne schöne Runde
futtern und dann
was auch immer machen. Nicht arbeiten, auf jeden Fall.
So, dann steht
ein bisschen rum. Also erstens, ihr müsst mal
drauf achten, wie viel die arbeitet
und ihr müsst mal drauf achten, wie lang die auf
der Arbeit ist.
Oh, wird wieder ein bisschen getrunken. Also im Prinzip besteht der Tag
nur aus, wir stehen rum und trinken Kaffee und spielen
ein bisschen mit Hunden und
haben jetzt nochmal gesnackt. Guck mal, es ist
fucking 17.10 Uhr
schon mittlerweile. 17.10 Uhr
Snacktime. Die war um
7.45 Uhr oder so
auf der Arbeit.
Was macht die überhaupt noch da?
Ist eine ernst gemeinte Frage.
Ja, nochmal ein bisschen mit den Hunden
spielen.
Das sieht auch nicht wirklich aus, als würde so was arbeiten.
Um 18.30 Uhr
Um 18.30 Uhr wird noch
ein bisschen Schach gespielt mit den Kollegen.
Ja. Und dann um
18.50 Uhr
gehen wir erstmal noch eine Runde Gewicht heben.
Dann gehen wir noch eine Runde
Wein trinken. Hat natürlich so viel mit der Arbeit
zu tun.
Und dann gehen wir nochmal was futtern, die sind den ganzen Tag am Essen.
Es ist, es ist
21.05 Uhr.
Na gut, die ist
hier, also hier ist sie heimgegangen.
Also sie ist heimgegangen
quasi hier um
was ist denn das?
18.00 Uhr, 19.00 Uhr.
19.00 Uhr.
Das heißt, die war von sieben,
die waren zwölf Stunden auf der Arbeit.
Zwölf Stunden, oder?
Nee, oder?
Big Mavs?
Okay, elf.
Die ist ja ein bisschen später hingegangen.
Sag mal, sie war elf
bis zwölf Stunden auf der Arbeit
und
davon hat die wie oft
was programmiert?
Zwo Stunden? Irgendwie so?
Oder 2.30?
Und der Rest,
der Rest ist so, wir hängen mit den
Leuten rum, trinken Kaffee, essen
ein bisschen was. Die hat im Prinzip
den ganzen Tag nichts gearbeitet.
Also okay,
die ist sieben Uhr aufgestanden, ist, wann ist sie
wieder daheim?
21.40 Uhr.
Hallo?
Ich meine, das Leben besteht noch aus ein bisschen mehr
als, ähm,
irgendwie
von morgens bis abends
irgendwie was mit der Arbeit zu tun zu haben.
Max, du redest hier ziemlich Quatsch.
Tja, ja, erhelle uns,
erhelle uns.
Also, ich weiß nicht.
Ähm, das sieht zwar cool aus
in den Videos immer.
Findest du den Job des Product Owners,
des Product Owners attraktiv?
Kommt drauf an, was die Aufgaben sind.
Das ist immer Definitionssache.
Übrigens, der Job, der wäre übrigens auch was
für mich, weil im Prinzip
ist sie den ganzen Tag nur am Futtern.
Ist halt der amerikanische Ansatz.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es der amerikanische Ansatz ist,
weil die Leute es so geil finden,
sondern weil sich manche Unternehmen ausgedacht haben,
ähm, es ist eine tolle Geschichte,
wenn die Leute quasi 24-7
freiwillig zur Verfügung stehen.
Hm.
Die hat sieben Pausen gemacht, weil die einmal kacken.
Ich glaube, das haben sie, das haben sie weggelassen, ähm.
Die hat sich nur die Snacks und Kaffee
kurz geholt und dann ist wieder zurück an die Arbeit.
Tja, wenn das so wäre,
das ist wahrscheinlich
auch so. Das ist wahrscheinlich
auch so. Aber die Frage ist,
wie sie das in dem Video
darstellen wollen. Und in dem Video
wird das definitiv nicht so dargestellt,
als hätte sie gearbeitet.
Wahrscheinlich hat die tatsächlich an dem Tag mehr gearbeitet.
Aber so wie das hier dargestellt wird,
auch von der zeitlichen Abfolge her, ist die,
wenn es hoch kommt, zwei Stunden am Arbeiten.
Das ist das Ziel. Natürlich ist es das Ziel.
Das Ziel ist,
dass es so aussieht, als wäre das ganz besonders toll
und natürlich auch richtig geil und super
voll allgemein akzeptiert
und alles, dass man quasi
24-7 für die Firma da ist.
Aber
es gibt viele solcher
Werbevideos
und die sind alle
ziemlich weit weg
von der Geschichte.
This is not real.
Das Video von ihm habe ich auch schon mal
geguckt. Der macht teilweise
hier ganz gute Videos, wenn es um
IT und Jobs geht. Wobei man sagen muss,
das ist natürlich die Ami-Sicht
der Dinge. Die haben ja
bei, war das bei Google?
Wo du sogar da
wohnen kannst und quasi auch sogar deine
Familie dahin umziehen kann?
Das Video ist in etwa das Äquivalent
zu einer Burger-Werbung. Die sehen in echt
auch nie so aus wie in der Werbung.
Ja, aber wusstet ihr, dass McDonalds
eine super Erklärung dafür hat, warum die
Burger auf den Bildern besser aussehen, als sie
in echt aussehen? Wusstet ihr, dass sie tatsächlich
eine offizielle
Erklärung abgegeben haben dazu?
Warum das so ist?
Und zwar sagt McDonalds,
das muss so sein, weil
die Burger auf
den Bildern darauf optimiert
sind, dass der Kunde erkennen kann,
was für Zutaten und
ja, Ingredients sind
Zutaten. Was für Zutaten
und zubereitet
und wieder zubereitet wird der Burger.
Deswegen sind die Bilder so, wie die Bilder sind.
Und in echt sehen die Burger anders aus,
weil sie dort geschmacksoptimiert sind.
Das sagt
McDonalds. Die sagen, die Bilder
sind, dass der Kunde sich ein besseres Bild über das Produkt
machen kann, was drauf ist. Und die
echten Burger sehen anders aus, weil sie geschmacksoptimiert
sind.
Könnt ihr nachgucken, das haben die wirklich
erzählt. Das ist
das ist Big Brain, Alter.
Okay, gucken wir mal das hier.
This is not real. A day in the life of software first edition.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was er dazu zu sagen hat.
Das habe ich glaube ich schon mal geguckt.
Leise, hä?
Ach, das liegt daran, weil ich hier leiser gemacht habe.
... für Videos.
And while they are really nice to watch
and they are fun to watch, I just don't think
that they reflect the reality of the dev world.
Yeah, there are some pretty cool jobs
out there. There are some jobs that
give you free food
all day long and have sleeping rooms like
Patrick's job. There are some pretty cool jobs out there.
But I think you should
see them as kind of like Instagram highlights
of software development.
Everyone is posting the best part about their job
or the best day of their job.
And I think that they could kind of
be almost like pandering to people's
hopes and dreams of what it's like to get
a software job. But why I'm
making this video is because I just wanted
to add some realism into it
and talk about like what actually
happens at work and what you don't see
in these videos and how
some of these videos almost, there's like more
eating in the video
than there is working.
How often you take breaks and how
that's, like it seems really awesome that you can take
lots of breaks and go hang out and do lots of stuff.
But then you end up working a 13 hour day.
Es hat vorhin irgendjemand
gefragt, wie das bei mir aussieht mit
Überstunden oder so.
Ich find's jetzt grad nicht.
Kannst du eigentlich pünktlich aus dem
Büro gehen oder musst du häufig länger arbeiten?
Ich gehe so gut wie immer pünktlich
aus dem Büro. Es sei denn,
es ist irgendwie eine
Veranstaltung, wo man das aber meistens vorher schon
weiß. Ich hau immer
exakt um 15.30 Uhr ab. Immer.
Freitag ist vielleicht auch schon
ein bisschen früher. Immer.
Ich bin 7 Uhr irgendwie so in dem Dreh
da und dann
hau ich immer Punkt 15.30 Uhr
fällt der Hammer.
So 7 bis 15.30 Uhr.
So in dem Dreh.
Plus minus paar Minuten, aber
spätestens 15.30 Uhr fällt bei mir
der Hammer, weil ich
muss ja noch, ich muss ja mit dem Zug heimfahren.
Da ist Schluss. Bam.
15.30 Uhr ist vorbei.
Dann lauf ich zum Südbahnhof in Frankfurt
Ich mache es ja morgens so.
Also ich könnte eigentlich locker
eine Stunde länger quasi
auf der Arbeit sein und mehr Stunden
machen oder früher heimgehen.
Ich laufe morgens eine halbe Stunde.
Also ich steige ja extra am anderen
Bahnhof aus. Ich laufe
morgens eine halbe Stunde dann zur Arbeit
und ich laufe mittags eine halbe Stunde
von der Arbeit zum Bahnhof. Einfach,
dass man ein bisschen Bewegung
hat.
Weil ansonsten so viel mit Bewegung
ist da halt nicht. Bei dem war ich
noch nicht.
Warum bist du kein Fan davon, dich für die Firma
einzusetzen und Karriere zu machen?
Ja, das ist persönliche Einstellungssache.
Also
ich habe da nichts dagegen,
wenn jetzt irgendeiner
sagt, er möchte irgendwie den Hardcore
Karrieregrind oder so machen.
Das kann jeder machen, jeder machen wie er will.
Aber ich denke, man sollte das
erstmal grundsätzlich, bevor man sich dafür
irgendwie entscheidet, man sollte das erstmal
grundsätzlich realistisch sehen.
Man ist nicht irgendwo auf der
Arbeit, weil die einen
so mögen, beziehungsweise man die selbst
so sehr mögen muss.
Die meisten, die meisten Unternehmen sind
natürlich da ganz scharf drauf,
quasi die Leute so ein bisschen
zu brainwashen, so nach dem Motto, dass sie
die geilsten, besten und sonst was auf der
Welt sind. Es ist auch nicht
verkehrt, weil man sich irgendwie mit seinem
Arbeitgeber identifizieren kann.
Es ist aber
sag mal so, zum Arbeiten und zum Spaß an
der Arbeit haben nicht
unbedingt erforderlich,
dass man die Firma an sich wahnsinnig geil
findet. Dazu
kommt, warum ich keinen
Bock auf Karrierestells habe, weil ich der Meinung
bin, es gibt Wichtigeres, was man machen
kann als arbeiten. Und in der Regel,
wenn du Karrierestells machen willst, das erste
was natürlich wichtig ist, ist,
dass du viele Leute, die wichtig sind, kennst und
dementsprechend auf den üblichen
Veranstaltungen, wo man sowas machen kann, da
ein bisschen rumhängt.
Weihnachtsfeier skippen, wie ich das mache, ist
schon mal nix. Sommerfest, Ostergeschiss
skippen, wie ich das mache, ist schon mal nix.
Generell
ist es auch ganz gut,
wenn man einen Chef hat, der die Sachen gut
verkauft. Das hilft auch schon mal.
Und natürlich, das Wichtigste ist,
es interessiert
sich keiner dafür,
ob man,
oder kaum einer,
also mehrere Stufen drüber,
ob man das macht,
ob man das gut macht und richtig macht,
was man immer macht. Das interessiert
eigentlich kaum einen,
wo man
kann, wenn man den Karriere-Client machen will,
ist,
vor allem in der IT geht das ganz gut,
wenn man,
angenommen, man dreht den ganzen Tag Däumchen,
aber dann
hat der Chef vom Chef vom Chef
irgendwie eine, wie nennt man es so schön, eine
Herzensangelegenheit, nennen sie das bei uns immer,
und
ihr habt quasi einen halben Monat Däumchen gedreht,
aber, sobald ihr mitkriegt,
dass der Chef vom Chef vom Chef, also
der Oberchef, dass der
irgendwas braucht, und ihr geht
dann da voll drauf ab und macht das in 30 Minuten,
das ist richtig nice und funktioniert,
dann seid ihr der absolute Held, ja.
Und das find ich dann geil,
dass du, dass du
jetzt irgendwie ansonsten, quasi
24, 24, nee, 24,7
nicht, aber quasi 340
Tage im Jahr
die Sache so machst, dass es funktioniert,
es juckt keinen, ja. Das sind die Sachen, die gesehen
werden. Und ehrlich
gesagt, habe ich auf so Geschiss nicht
sonderlich viel Bock.
Es gibt ja auch,
sag mal, es gibt ja grundsätzlich zwei Varianten,
ähm,
wo jetzt auch immer mehr Unternehmen mittlerweile
drauf kommen, und zwar,
dass, also früher war es ja so,
du konntest quasi, so dieses,
dieser klassische Karriere,
ähm, Karrieregeschichte
war, erstens natürlich,
dass man viele Leute kennt, und
zweitens, dass man irgendwie
irgendwelche
Organisationen-
management-Funktionen ausübt.
Das war früher so der einzige
Karriereweg, den es, den es
so richtig gegeben hat. Ähm, das Problem
war natürlich nur, dass viele Leute, die sich für Technik
interessieren, dass die absolut keinen Bock
haben auf irgendwelche Personalverantwortung,
auf irgendwelche Führungsgeschichten, auf irgendwelche
Management-Organisationskram. Da haben
die keinen Bock drauf. Und,
ähm, deswegen kommen jetzt immer
mehr Unternehmen glücklicherweise auf den Trichter,
dass es nicht verkehrt
ist, wenn man, äh,
auch Leuten, die sich für Technik interessiert,
Optionen bietet.
Und das ist was, da habe ich überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Das würde ich auch nicht, würde ich auch, würde ich
auch machen, wenn es da eine passende
Position gebe, beziehungsweise ich
den Arbeitsaufwand reinstecken
wollte, den es
da gibt.
Aber aktuell komme ich ja eh schon hin und vorne nicht hin.
Und außerdem bin ich der Meinung, ähm,
das muss aber jeder
selbst sehen für sich, dass man nicht
unbedingt nur lebt, um zu arbeiten.
Also sprich, ähm,
man muss sich halt überlegen, was einem wichtig
ist. Wenn man sagt, ja, ich will hier irgendwie
in irgendeiner Firma
vorwärts kommen, was auch immer das für ein High ist,
okay, kann ja jeder machen, wie er will, aber ich
will ehrlich gesagt pünktlich heimgehen und
ne Runde YouTube-Videos machen und ne Runde,
keine Ahnung, äh, Overwatch,
Borderlands oder sonst was spielen.
So, und das
alles in Kombination kannst du halt nicht machen.
Okay, es geht nicht alles, es geht
nicht alles gleichzeitig. Äh, ja,
im Vertrieb ist das, ist das, ist das anders,
ja, klar, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Mein Chef meint, dass wir als, was, äh,
Mitarbeiter gleichzeitig für die Firma aufbringen.
Ne, das Einzige, was du machst, musst du nicht.
Das Einzige, was du machen musst, was übrigens,
was oftmals vergessen wird, was
beide Seiten machen müssen, ähm, ähm,
ähm, Alter,
ähm, ähm,
das Einzige, was du machen musst, ist,
und was die Firma auch machen muss, in der du arbeitest,
ist das erfüllen, was im Arbeitsvertrag drinne
steht. Wenn da drinne steht, 40
Stunden,
dann steht da nicht, man kann
nicht einfach sagen, so nach dem Motto, ja,
das haben wir unterschrieben, das juckt mich nicht.
Das gilt für beide Seiten.
Was du da unterschrieben hast, musst du machen,
und was da drin steht, müssen die anderen auch machen.
Das ist das Einzige, was du machen musst.
Was dein Chef dazu denkt,
äh, wenn du den Chef hast, der irgendwie,
ähm, äh, der Meinung
ist, er muss 70 Stunden die Woche
arbeiten, dann kann er das, ja, kann er das gerne denken,
aber das muss man nicht machen.
Also, ich würd das, ich würd das auch nicht machen. Und,
ähm, ähm,
glücklicherweise ist es bei uns auch nicht so,
ähm, wartet mal, ich will mal was trinken,
ähm,
sozusagen, glücklicherweise ist es
bei uns auch nicht so, die gucken da eigentlich schon ganz
gut drauf, dass du nicht zu viele Überstunden hast, ja.
Ähm, weil, es ist ja sogar
erwiesen mittlerweile, dass
Leute, die, ähm,
die ausgeglichen sind,
die da Spaß an der Sache haben, die nicht
so sehr gestresst sind,
dass die bessere Arbeit abliefern.
Und, das ist ja auch ne Sache,
die ist eigentlich ganz logisch.
Also, ich sprech jetzt mal für Leute, die,
sagen wir mal, was programmieren oder was
administrieren oder sich um,
um IT-Architektur
kümmern oder sowas.
So grob in diesem Bereich. Muss man sagen,
zum größten Teil hat es schon
ne gewisse Portion,
äh, Kreativität, die dabei
ist, ja. Da ist schon ne gewisse,
ne gewisse Portion Kreativität dabei.
Es ist, jetzt mal unabhängig
davon, was man genau macht, ja. Also,
wenn einer sagt,
ähm, dass das
Programmieren oder Entwickeln
gleich Code eintippen ist,
ist Schwachsinn. Das hat damit überhaupt nichts
zu tun.
Ähm,
so. Und deswegen
ist halt auch die Sache
so, wenn man,
wenn man gestresst ist,
kann man nicht kreativ sein. Das ist ne,
das ist ne Kombination, die passt nicht zusammen.
Wenn du gestresst bist,
dann bist du quasi, ähm,
im, im, im Fluchtmodus,
sozusagen, ja. Du willst weg.
Und wenn man, und wenn man weg will, ist man nicht kreativ.
Das, das beißt sich, ja. Also,
wenn jemand mal von nem Hund weggerannt ist,
zum Beispiel, dann ist man ziemlich unter Stress.
Ähm, und
ich glaub, keiner ist, während er mal von nem Hund
weggerannt ist, hat sich dann zwischendrin
überlegt, der Sinn des
Lebens.
Oh, guckt euch mal diesen Baum hier an.
Aha. Ja, das ist keiner.
Wenn, wenn du wegrennst, wenn du
unter Stress bist, dann rennst du und machst dir da keine
großartigen anderen Gedanken drunter, ja.
Bruder muss los. Und deswegen
funktioniert das nicht. Deswegen funktionieren
generell Sachen, wo man kreativ
sein muss, und Sachen, wo man sich
konzentrieren muss, oder fokussiert sein muss,
geht nicht. Konzentriert
sein, auf alles außer
abhauen, geht unter Stress, unter,
unter, ähm, irgendwelchen
Adrenalineinfluss, geht nicht.
Das ist auch so ne Sache, ist, du hast ja auch in anderen
Berufen, ähm, bist du schon mal
vor nem Hund weggerannt? Ja, bin ich schon.
Im Urlaub, in Port, in Portugal war das, glaub ich.
Da rennen viele Hunde frei rum, und der eine
war halt der Meinung, er muss jetzt mal hinter, hinter paar
Leuten herrennen. Und das weiß ich noch, da, meine Mutter
hat dann damals gesagt, so nach dem Motto,
da bleib stehen, da tut nix, wenn du wegrennst,
flippt er noch mehr aus. Und ich bin halt gerannt,
wie sonstwas, weil das Ding sah halt übelst
gefährlich aus. Und der Witz ist,
ich bin weggerannt, und
er hat dann jemand anderes gebissen. Also
von wegen, wär ich stehen geblieben, wär ich stehen geblieben,
wär, äh, ja,
wär keine gute Idee gewesen, ne?
Richtig, richtig beknackt.
Naja, ähm,
das ist in anderen Berufen ja auch so.
Wenn ich mir zum Beispiel angucke, dass es, dass es
Ärzte gibt, oder so, die dann, was weiß ich,
auch, auch zweistellige, äh,
Schichtdinger machen am Stück, und
dann quasi am Ende nochmal irgendeinen operieren sollen,
oder so. Wie soll, wie soll
man mit, mit, wie soll man
ruhig und fokussiert
das machen, nachdem man, nachdem man
quasi gestresst ist? Das kann doch eigentlich gar nicht richtig
funktionieren. Und es
kommt nicht von ungefähr,
dass in, ähm,
dass in Berufen, wo man
sich konzentrieren muss, oder auch in,
in, sagen wir mal, in Entwicklung und Forschung
und, und so, Science-Geschichten,
dass da immer mehr Leute sich
irgendwelche Beruhigungsmittel,
Schrägstrich, ähm,
Gehirn,
wie, wie
nennt man solche Mittel, wo man sich besser,
wo man sich besser fokussieren kann, ja, oder auch irgendwelche
Pro-Gamer, dass die sich irgendwelche
Sachen reinhauen, wo sie
einfach länger am Stück fokussiert denken
können.
Das ist halt das Problem, wenn du ne, wenn du
ein Umfeld hast, was eigentlich
Kreativitäts, äh,
Fokussierungs-mäßig
feindlich ist, und es wird trotzdem
verlangt, dass du dich immer mehr konzentrierst.
Aber das kann ja nicht funktionieren.
Ne, nicht Ritalin. Die nehmen, die nehmen den Krams,
die, die, die, die auch ganzen
ADHS-Leute kriegen.
Es gab doch mal vor ner Weile diesen
Skandal von vor, vor drei,
vier Jahren, wo einer gesagt hat,
dass die ganzen CSGO-Pros
vor, äh, nem Turnier sich alle,
sich alle, ähm,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich's
jetzt alles Zeugs
einschmeißen, ähm,
dass die halt, äh,
in CS besser fünf Minuten
auf ne Ecke fokussiert gucken können, ob sich da
ein Pixel verändert.
Das ist Ritalin, ja, kann sein.
Ähm, der Iambumsa,
ach, ne, haha, falsch hab ich
verlesen, nicht
Iambumsa, leihbumster,
hehehe,
Iambumsa wär natürlich auch nicht
verkehrt gewesen.
Ähm, ähm, sagt,
in der aktuellen Firma
haben wir eine 35-Stunden-Woche.
Leider wird auf jeden Einzelnen so viel draufgebracht,
dass alle komplett überlastet
sind. Nachher wird, ähm,
aber
verbreitet, dass wir aufpassen sollen, live
Ja, das ist, das ist so ein typischer Fall
von, ähm,
auf der einen Seite wird das erzählt und dann das andere
gemacht. Das hast du bei jedem, bei jedem Laden.
Genauso wie jeder Laden erzählt,
dass, ähm, sie die geilsten
in irgendeinem, in irgendeinem Bereich sind.
Die,
die Sache ist nur die, ähm,
oder,
es ist schwierig, also, man kann
jetzt nicht pauschal sagen, so nach dem Motto,
ey, äh,
kann man nicht mitmachen, weil ich weiß, es ist,
also, es ist prinzipiell schwierig,
oder, es, es,
es kann schwierig sein, je nachdem wie man so
ist, äh, wie man so drauf ist,
bei gewissen Sachen nicht mitzumachen,
ähm,
die quasi allgemein
akzeptiert sind, dort wo man ist.
Das ist, das ist, das ist ein bisschen
schwierig und eigentlich
kann man da auch wenig
dagegen machen, weil du kannst, du kannst
dich natürlich aufregen, ja, super,
dann, dann sagen sie hier, du bist kein Teamplayer
oder irgendwie sowas, ähm,
es, es ist schwierig,
es ist schwierig, ja, also eigentlich, eigentlich
müssten das die, müssten das, müssten das die Firma
selbst irgendwie checken, aber es ist
tatsächlich sehr widersprüchlich, ja, es ist,
es ist sehr widersprüchlich zu sagen, ähm,
ihr habt 35 Stunden
Woche, achtet auf, auf, äh,
gesunde Mischung aus Arbeit und Freizeit
und dann, ähm, musst du so viel arbeiten,
was unbedingt fertig werden muss, wo dir die Leute
aus dem Sack gehen und du kommst in 35 Stunden
nicht hin. Das ist ein Problem, das ist aber, äh,
ein organisatorisches Problem von der, von
dem jeweiligen Laden, also.
Das ist schwierig, ja. Ich verlasse
die Firma übrigens auch, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist, das ist im Prinzip auch eines der
wenigen Sachen, die man, die man tatsächlich machen kann.
Das ist, so, so, so blöd wie's
klingt, weil die meisten
Läden tun sich
unglaublich schwer damit,
grundlegende Sachen zu ändern.
Das ist sehr eingefahren, genauso wie es eingefahren
ist bei mir, wie ich hier mein Zeug
angeordnet hab oder sonst was, sind
Abläufe in, in Unternehmen sind
unglaublich eingefahren, vor allem, wenn's die schon
seit einer Weile gibt.
Das ist sehr eingefahren und was halt
viele, was halt viele Unternehmen dann gerne
machen ist, die holen sich vielleicht, äh,
irgendwelche Beratungstypen oder irgendwelche,
irgendwelche Leute, Coaches
oder sonst was, die erklären ihnen, dass das eigentlich nicht gut
ist, wie das, wie das läuft, so wie dies
halt gemacht wird, weil die Sachen so eingefahren
sind und dann wird dann groß verkündet so nach
dem Motto, ah, das ändern wir jetzt und dann
gibt's dann auch zig Veranstaltungen zu
so nach dem Motto, ah ja, hier unsere neue
Vision und
ähm, das wird dann
verkündet und danach
was das?
Die neue Vision wird verkündet und fertig.
Und es ändert sich nichts.
Ähm,
und es gibt Läden, da hab ich letztens
auch einen schönen Vortrag von irgendeinem Professor
zugesehen auf YouTube, es gibt halt Firmen
oder Unternehmen, die
machen das halt
regelmäßig, so alle paar Monate
und, ähm,
da hat er gesagt,
die Leute kapieren das mit der Zeit
und machen dann einfach folgendes,
wenn es heißt, es gibt jetzt neue
Änderungen, die ultra wichtig sind und
neue Visionen, dann gehen die einfach
zwei, drei Wochen in Deckung,
äußern sich nicht dazu,
rühren sich nicht, machen nix, weil sie
wissen, danach kommt
schon wieder was Neues. Also ich weiß
nicht mehr, wie er das genannt hat, irgendwie
irgendwie
Pendelinnovation oder irgendwie so,
also quasi, es kommt was Neues,
du weißt im Prinzip, dass es nicht länger
als drei Wochen Bestand haben wird und
was die Leute machen, ist so nach dem Motto,
wuh, ich weiche der Sache mal aus, weil ich weiß,
wenn ich der Sache drei Wochen ausgewichen bin, da kommt eh schon wieder was Neues.
Also da kann man
auch schon in viele Fallen tappen.
Ähm,
äh, 40-Stunden-Woche ist für euch
zu viel, kommt auf die einzelne
Person an, also ich, mittlerweile
muss ich sagen, ich persönlich
finde, dass
40 Stunden die Woche zu viel sind, ich arbeite
ja auch nur noch vier Tage die Woche, also sprich,
vier mal so irgendwie 7,7
oder so ist es, glaube ich, bei uns
irgendwie so in dem Dreh, wie viel habe ich
eigentlich hier, vier mal
7,7, ah
30, ungefähr, 30,
31 Stunden habe ich so ungefähr
in der Woche. Und ich muss euch
ehrlich sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr,
wie ich das überhaupt hingekriegt
habe, ähm,
fünf Wochen, äh,
fünf Tage die Woche zuzuarbeiten.
Wie viel Geld verdienst du,
ich weiß es selber nicht genau.
Ist jetzt kein, ist jetzt kein Witz.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also spätestens
seit ich seit ein paar Jahren vier Tage die Woche arbeite,
ich habe das noch nie jetzt
ausgerechnet, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe letztens mal so grob überschlagen, weil
ich gesagt habe, ich muss meinem Chef mal wieder auf den Sack gehen,
dass ich mehr Kohle kriege, nicht weil ich unbedingt mehr
Kohle bräuchte, sondern weil ich der Meinung
bin, dass ich, ich meine, auch durch diese
YouTube-Geschichte, weil ich halt mittlerweile
mir eigentlich bei den,
wisst ihr, wenn man irgendwann mal
genug Kohle hat, wenn man jetzt nicht
jemand ist, der gerne sich irgendwie eine Rolex-Karte
kaufen will oder einen Porsche oder so,
wenn du irgendwann mal genug Kohle hast, dass du dir
eigentlich ohne die Sachen zweimal
rumzudrehen, dir immer die Sachen
holen kannst, wenn es jetzt halt nicht gerade ein neues
fettes Auto oder ein Haus oder sonst was ist.
Wenn du dir so die Standardsachen immer holen kannst,
wenn du sie haben willst, dann machst du dir da weniger,
weniger Gedanken drum.
Und, ähm, deswegen weiß ich gar nicht,
wie es ist. Es ist jetzt aber nicht übertrieben
viel oder so. Ich denke, das ist
für Frankfurter Verhältnisse ganz okay,
aber ich, ich weiß es, ich weiß schlicht und klar nicht.
Ja, zumindest, äh, ich habe letztens mal
so ein bisschen grob überschlagen, aber das ist auch schon wieder
ein Jahr her, weil ich beim Chef mal wieder auf den Keks
gehen wollte, dass ich mal wieder langsam mal ein bisschen mehr
Kohle kriege, ähm, was vor allem daran liegt,
weil ich mir die letzten Jahre überhaupt,
überhaupt gar nichts in dieser Richtung,
äh, irgendwie unternommen
habe, ja. Ich habe im Prinzip
die Leute in Ruhe gelassen,
ähm, und nicht mit sowas
genervt, jetzt wird es mal wieder Zeit ab und so muss das sein.
Und außerdem mache ich auch genug Dinger,
die, äh, aus meiner Sicht auch der Firma
was bringen und, ähm,
von, von Weihnachtsfeiern,
Sommerfesten und irgendwie warmen Worten
hat man ja im Prinzip auch nix, ne.
Und es passt auch nicht zusammen und das ist
eine Sache, wo ich denke, was viele,
was viele Unternehmen auch machen, ist,
da wird jedes Jahr, vor allem welche,
vor allem welche, die an der Börse sind
oder aber die anderweitig
irgendwie gut dastehen müssen,
finanztechnisch,
die erzählen quasi jedes Jahr,
dass das vergangene Jahr ein ganz
tolles Jahr gewesen ist.
So nach dem Motto, wir haben jetzt wieder ein neue,
einen neuen Rekord erreicht im, im Bereich
XY. Wir haben jetzt wieder
eine neue Auszeichnung gewonnen, blablabla.
Und eine Sache,
die, ähm, die ich da immer nicht verstehe
ist, wie passt
das zusammen, weil ich hab das, ich hab das
von ein paar Kollegen mitgekriegt, die,
die wollten, die sind zu ihrem Chef gegangen und haben
gesagt, äh, wie sieht's denn da aus, mehr Kohle?
Und da muss der eine wohl wortwörtlich
gesagt haben, ähm, weil er sich raus
reden wollte, ne, also,
da sind mir die Hände gebunden, wo ich
mir auch gedacht hab, alter, wenn an dieser Position
so, so, so blöde Ausreden kommen,
also der Witz ist ja, man kann
nicht, man kann nicht,
ähm, fünf
Jahre in Folge immer neue Rekorde
und Beste und sonst was, äh, verkünden,
so nach dem Motto, wir sind die geilsten,
wir sind noch geiler, noch geiler als geil,
die Oberultra geilsten und jetzt,
und jetzt Worldwide die geilsten
und dann sagen, so
nach dem Motto, okay, also wir verdienen jedes Jahr
mehr Geld, wir machen jedes Jahr
mehr Gewinn, wir machen jedes Jahr mehr Umsatz, wir machen
jedes Jahr, äh, zig neue Leute
dazu, wir haben jedes Jahr das, wir haben
jedes Jahr weniger Konkurrenz, aber
Moment, also wenn einer, der da dran
beteiligt ist, sagt, er möchte auch
davon irgendwie was abmachen, ne, dann sind
mir die Hände gebunden, ja, das ist natürlich
äh, Blödsinn, ja,
ähm, und das, das ist einfach so ein,
wo ich mir denke, das passt irgendwie nicht so ganz
zusammen, deswegen bin ich auch ganz
froh, dass ich mich an irgendwelchem
großartigen Karriere-Crime
nicht beteilige, sondern ich
mach das, was mir Spaß macht und ansonsten
ist mein Hauptlebensinhalt nicht arbeiten
gehen, so ist jede Firma, ja,
aber man muss das denen auch ab und zu mal aufs Brot schmieren,
dass es, ähm, zumindest
aus eigen-, also aus meiner Sicht
oder aus der Sicht der Leute, die es betreffen, dass es nicht
zusammenpasst, ja,
weil es ist bei vielen Sachen
so, ich mein, das ändern wird sich, äh,
ändern wird sich da, ändern wird sich
da nichts dran, aber es gibt
teilweise ganz merkwürdige Reaktionen drauf, wenn
man die Leute mal mit sowas konfrontiert,
ja, wenn man da einfach nur so blöd fragt, so
sag mal, wie kann das, oder wie, wie, wie
wie passt das eigentlich zusammen?
passt das eigentlich zusammen?
Dann, dann geraten die Leute zumindest mal ein bisschen in Erklärungsnot,
ja, es kommt
aber auch ein bisschen auf den Laden an. Äh, arbeitest
du nach Tarifvertrag, hat jemand gefragt, ja,
mach ich.
Also, das setzt sich zusammen aus
Tarifvertrag plus Bonus.
Also du, du, im Prinzip ist
es ja so,
was da im Tarifvertrag drinne steht, ist
das Mindeste, was dir bezahlt
werden muss auf dieser Position.
Das heißt nicht, dass dir nicht mehr bezahlt werden darf
und, ähm,
ja.
Ich mein, wir können uns den aktuellen Tarifvertrag
mal angucken, wenn ihr wollt.
Da können, da kann, da können wir zumindest so grob
erkennen, was ich verdiene an Kohle.
Aber wie gesagt,
da kommt, da kommt, äh, noch, noch
Zeug, noch Zeug
drauf. Ich bin mir aber auch gar
nicht, ähm, gar nicht sicher,
in welchem Tarifvertrag wir genau sind.
Ich glaub, wir sind im Tarifvertrag für,
für Bank und Versicherung?
Nicht Metall, nein, nein.
Wir sind in,
ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Nicht Verdi, nicht Verdi,
oder? Sind wir Verdi?
Da seht ihr mal, wie geil ich mich damit auskenne,
ähm,
die V-Gewerkschaften,
ne, ne, ne, ne.
Wenn ich die, wenn ich die,
auch nicht,
Finanz,
Leistung vielleicht,
ne, wir sind nicht
bei Verdi, das weiß ich, ähm,
was gibt's denn da noch alles so?
Ist die Musik eigentlich grad so leise?
Oh Mist, wir,
wie heißt denn der Laden, wo wir,
ja, ich arbeite zwar bei ner Bank,
aber die machen das ja taktisch geschickt,
ähm, man arbeitet ja nicht,
man ist ja immer nicht direkt bei dieser Bank
angestellt, sondern bei irgendeinem Subding,
was dann da die IT-Dienstleistung
für die Bank macht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich steuerlich, ähm,
günstiger.
Versicherung?
Ich such mal nach Versicherung.
Das,
das hier, ja, das sind die,
glaub ich.
Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube, die sind dafür zuständig
bei uns.
Jetzt ist die Musik zu laut?
Okay, das kann sich nicht entscheiden, irgendwie.
So, hä?
So, also, ich glaube, das ist
der Versicherer
als Arbeitgeber.
So, okay, ähm,
wo sind jetzt,
wo sind jetzt die Tarifverträge hier?
Tarifbehandlung, Tarifverträge?
Oh, die ganzen Subs hab ich ja
schon vergessen. Äh,
Flix.at, Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön, zwei Monate. Ähm, ich muss mal
nachgucken, ich hab ganz vergessen,
ganz vergessen, die ganzen
Subscribers heute zu
erwähnen. Und zwar, wen haben wir denn da alles?
Wir haben, der
Brauner Marok ist am Start, äh,
Twitch Prime, und
dann haben wir Daniel Lull,
Silent Pain,
und Flex.at, Dankeschön, alle für
die Subs. Silent Pain
sogar vier Monate in Folge.
Huge, big brain, IQ ist wieder
steil hoch hier im Chat.
So, okay, ähm,
wo ist jetzt hier, wo ist jetzt hier der, der
Gehaltstarifvertrag in der
App? Das müsste der eigentlich sein.
Okay, also,
ist der das? Also, ich bin Gehalts-
Ey.
Eins davon bin ich.
Da seht ihr mal, ich hab kein, ich hab
echt keinen Plan, so richtig, was
ich, was ich verdiene. Ich bin eins, eins
davon. Und vor allem, ich bin auf
jeden Fall ab vierzehnte. Ich bin auf jeden Fall ab
vierzehn, ja, vierzehn links.
Ähm, eins davon
bin ich. Wir können einfach mal beides ausrechnen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Da ist, wie gesagt,
Bonus und so kommt ja alles noch dabei.
Ähm, falls man einen bekommt.
Also, sprich, das, was man hier sieht,
ist wirklich nur das Mindeste,
was einem bezahlt werden muss,
wenn quasi der jeweilige Arbeitgeber
da in dieser, diesen Tarifvertrag
unterschrieben hat, und, ähm,
ihr in dieser passenden Gehaltsgruppe seid.
Das ist das Mindeste, was, und, und,
im Berufsjahr. Das ist das Mindeste, was ihr,
das heißt nicht, dass ihr nicht mehr bekommen könnt,
beziehungsweise, das heißt auch nicht, dass ihr einfach,
ähm, in eine andere Gehaltsgruppe eingruppiert
werden könnt oder so.
So, also, was, was, ähm,
füllt sich ab? Okay.
Nehmen wir jetzt mal, nehmen wir mal das hier.
Das ist, das ist im Monat.
Ähm, what?
Kann man das nicht copy & pasten?
Hallo? Copy & pasten?
Das sind 880 mal 14.
Wir kriegen 14 Jahresgehälter.
Also sind wir bei
54.320.
Das ist das, das ist so die Basic-Sache,
die quasi bezahlt wird,
rein nach dem Tarifvertrag.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal gucken, ob das, ob das auch stimmt,
was ich hier erzähle.
Was ist das? Gültig ab
erstes Berufsjahr, Fahrtkostenzuschuss.
Ja, was bei uns auch geil ist, wir kriegen das,
wir kriegen die komplette Fahrkarte mittlerweile,
ähm, günstiger.
Nicht komplett bezahlt, aber günstiger.
Verantwortungszulagen
gibt's dann noch.
Also ich kann's euch nicht genau sagen, ähm,
weil bei mir kommt noch ein bisschen was oben drauf.
Und da weiß ich auch, ich hab echt keine Ahnung.
Also gehen wir mal von aus, dass es irgendwie,
äh, was haben wir gesagt? Irgendwie 55.000
über den Daumen gepeilt waren das.
Und davon
ziehen wir jetzt irgendwie nochmal
55.000. Wie viel müssen wir
dann nochmal abziehen? 20% oder so?
Ne? Stimmt das, was ich da mache?
Also müsste ich das,
das mal 14 kriegen.
Ne, Moment.
Äh, fast, fast, ähm,
nochmal eine 0 hinten dran.
Also müsste ich im Jahr mindestens 44,
äh, mal 0,8, ja, ist eigentlich viel, viel
sinnvoller. Ja. Kommt aber halt aufs
Gleiche raus. Also müsste ich
mindestens im Jahr das hier
kriegen bei, äh, 4
Tagen die Woche. Laut Tarifvertrag.
Aber ich gehe davon aus,
das rechnet sich nicht exakt so.
Aber so
ungefähr, ungefähr so eine Hausnummer
ist das. So über den Daumen gepeilt kann
man das, glaube ich, jetzt mal ganz gut einschätzen.
Wahrscheinlich Bonus.
Äh, ne, also
es gibt, es gibt, ähm,
je nachdem, was, äh, ansteht,
gibt es so, wie,
wie nennt man das, ähm, nochmal
zusätzlich quasi so, so, so,
keine Ahnung, wie heißt denn das irgendwie?
Man hat sich besonders hervorgetan, Bonus
irgendwie. Also irgendwie
die, man hat hier so besonders tolle
Sachen abgeschlossen oder Prämie,
Prämie, ja, genau, das klingt gut.
Ähm, das gibt es.
Ähm, aber,
ich weiß, dass bei mir im Vertrag
ist halt so eine extra Sektion, die nicht
abhängig ist von irgendwelchen
Projekten oder sonst was.
Das kommt einfach immer nochmal, nochmal
dazu. Deswegen, das ist das
Mindeste, was man bezahlt kriegen muss, wenn eben
der Arbeitgeber in diesem Tarifvertrag
drinne ist, man in dieser, ähm,
wenn man diese Berufserfahrung hat,
bloß halt in dieser Gehaltsgruppe
einsortiert ist. So.
Das ist jetzt natürlich, wenn man jetzt mal mal
die, die YouTube-Geschichten und, äh,
irgendwelche Sellout-Geschichten und auch hier
Subscriber-Geschichten, wenn man das mal außen vor lässt,
ähm,
ist das, was wollte ich jetzt sagen,
ist das jetzt natürlich weit davon entfernt,
was, was manch andere hier
sich, äh, die Rolex gönnen können,
irgendwie im Monat oder so, aber
das bewegt sich auch ohne alle anderen
Einnahmen, die es noch irgendwie dazu gibt,
ähm,
so in dem Bereich, wo man
halt sagen kann, okay,
ähm, eigentlich interessiert's
einen nicht mehr so wirklich,
ähm,
wieviel's jetzt hinterm Komma genau
ist, sondern
man kommt damit wirklich gut, gut
aus, ja. Also,
wenn ich der Meinung bin, ey, ich brauch irgendwie
keine Ahnung, ne Klimaanlage,
kann ich mir ne Klimaanlage kaufen.
Oder wenn ich, wenn ich irgendwie sag, hier,
ich hätte gern mein Klo mit Spülung, kann
ich mir das auch kaufen. Ich mein, ich kann mir davon
jetzt natürlich nicht irgendwie
drei Häuser kaufen oder so,
ähm,
aber ich will mir auch keine drei Häuser kaufen.
Ich hab nur ein Haus, das reicht.
Genug.
So, genug mit Arbeit, Arbeitssachen.
Heftig.
Wie hast du jetzt eigentlich deine aktuelle Katze genannt?
Gar nicht. Ja, die heißt schon
seit Anfang an so hier, guck.
Tschi.
Wo ist sie? Ah.
Also, eigentlich heißt sie Chico,
aber Chico, Chico klingt irgendwie
nicht so weiblich. Deswegen sag ich immer,
deswegen sag ich manchmal Chica oder Chico,
eins von beiden.
Und die reagiert da auch voll drauf.
Dachte, die ist,
nein, die nicht. Das ist schon die dritte.
Ich hatte ja nicht so viel Glück mit, mit
den, ähm, mit Katze
FPS.
Das ist jetzt innerhalb von ein paar Jahren
schon die dritte. Die erste,
die hier, ähm,
das hier war die erste,
die hatte ich vom, vom Nachbar,
der wohnt ja da nicht mehr, also der
ist ja, was heißt der wohnt da nicht mehr, der ist, äh,
hinüber, ja.
Ähm, und die hat
eines Tages dort im Hof gestanden, hat rumgemauzt.
Und
da hab ich ihr was zu essen gegeben und seitdem,
äh, hat sie sich gedacht,
okay, dann zieh ich einfach nebenan
ein. Die war aber
halt auch schon alt, die war 14 oder so.
Und, ähm,
die, ihr kennt ja, ihr kennt ja vielleicht
noch ein paar Videos, die war ja ein paar Videos dabei.
So, ähm,
die war aber halt schon relativ alt, ja, die hat dann
andere Probleme gehabt und,
so, und danach hatte ich
Barbie, die heißt halt wirklich so,
ich hab sie nicht so genannt, ja, also die heißt
polnisch, glaube ich,
Barbie, ähm,
und,
Barbie, ich hätte meine Katze nie Barbie
genannt, ja.
Die hatte ich nur,
die hatte ich nur ein,
ein Dreivierteljahr, halbes Jahr, Dreivierteljahr,
weil die war von Anfang an schon
krank, das wusste man damals bloß nicht.
So, und jetzt,
und jetzt habe ich Chico,
und, aber die ist auch
alt, ja, die sind alle alt, die sind alle zehn plus.
Ähm,
und, aber der
geht's gut. Das ist auch die erste
reine, reine Wohnungskatze.
Ich meine, die könnten ja theoretisch
bei uns zumindest in Hof und auch teilweise
in Garten, wobei Garten, Garten
eher nicht mehr so, da kommt die, glaube ich, nicht rein.
Ähm, aber die
will nicht raus.
Die will nicht raus. Die war immer
wohnunggewöhnt und die geht
nicht raus. Wenn ich die
Haustür aufmache,
wenn ich die, wenn ich die Haustür aufmache,
dann geht die immer hinter die Treppe und versteckt
sich. So nach dem Motto,
nicht, dass der mich rausschmeißt oder so.
Die will nicht raus.
Was die aber macht ist,
ähm, die legt sich immer unten
im Badezimmer, legt die sich aufs
Fensterbrett oder halt auf die, da
überm Klo und guckt
raus und, und guckt dann immer
zu, wie die Vögel draußen Zeug fressen.
Aber selbst wird die nie im Leben rauswollen.
Ja.
Alte Rentnerin am Fenster. Ja, ist echt
so. Warum holst du dir
keine jungen Katzen? Ähm,
weil ich denke, also erstens, das hat mehrere
Gründe. Ähm,
alte Katzen werden besonders schlecht
vermittelt und alte Katzen
nehmen jetzt halt auch irgendwie nicht mehr irgendwie
15 Jahre oder so. Deswegen ist es
scheiße, wenn sie die letzten, letzten paar Jahre,
natürlich kann die auch noch 10 Jahre leben, aber Katzen
können dann auch 20 plus werden, das ist kein Problem.
Ähm, da irgendwie im Tierheim rumgammeln
ist kacke. Dazu kommt, dass
alte Katzen eigentlich am wenigsten,
gern vermittelt werden, also viele
Leute wollen keine alten Katzen.
Und, dass man
den Vorteil hat, wenn man alte, wenn man
sich eine alte Katze holt, man weiß, was
man kriegt. Das ist echt so,
man weiß, was man kriegt. Ähm,
wenn du dich mit einer alten Katze verstehst,
und, ähm, die sich mit dir versteht,
das ist eigentlich das Wichtigere,
dann kannst du davon ausgehen, die ist halt so.
Der musst du auch nichts mehr beibringen.
Du weißt, wenn, wenn man
zusammenpasst, dann passt man zusammen, das passt.
Die entwickeln dann auch nicht irgendwelche, irgendwelche
Macken oder so. Die wissen auch alle,
wie man, wie man schön, äh, kacken geht.
Richtig, oder sowas.
Also ich, ich find alte
Katzen, vor allem, vor allem
ein Vorteil von alten Katzen ist,
die sind halt super
entspannt. Ja, ich mein, Katzen pennen allgemein
schon viel, aber alte Katzen
pennen ja nur. Was für eine Web-App
läuft da bei dir? Das ist hier mein Tool, wo ich
Sachen, äh, Bilder
auferleihen kann. Hat deine Katze
auch ein automatisiertes Klo? Nee,
aber die hat zwei Stück. Die hat unten
unter der Treppe eins, wo man
mit, mit Dach drüber und
oben bei mir in dieser
Abstellküche hat die, ähm,
auch noch eins hinter der Tür stehen.
Die braucht das auch, die geht da regelmäßig auf
alle hin, hin und zurück.
Bist du gesund so allgemein? Ja.
Ich bin gesund.
Und damit das so bleibt,
ähm, lauf
ja jetzt jeden Tag 2x30 Minuten am Tag.
Weil nichts ist eigentlich
schädlicher, oder eines der schädlichsten
Sachen, die du überhaupt machen kannst, ist, einfach
den ganzen Tag sitzen. Das ist
die beschissenste Position überhaupt.
Deswegen hab ich mir auch daheim,
ähm, also deswegen nicht nur daheim,
so auf der Arbeit, deswegen hab ich überall einen Stehschreibtisch
und, ähm,
versuch mich zumindest ein bisschen zu
bewegen, was aber halt, ehrlich gesagt,
nicht so gut,
nicht so einfach in den Ablauf passt.
Ja. Weil ich meine,
ich will ja, wenn ich von der Arbeit fertig bin,
will ich ja eigentlich direkt daheim mein
YouTube-Streaming und sonst was Zeug machen.
Stehschreibtische sind nice,
ja. Sehr nice.
Ui-upscaling
das 2. Okay.
Das sieht ehrlich gesagt aus wie ein
Schärfefilter von Photoshop,
der es, äh,
der es irgendwie
nur Fake-schärfer macht.
Oder? Ich meine,
das sieht aus wie so ein
Schärfefilter von
Photoshop, der das so irgendwie so, so,
der es so besonders crisp aussehen
lässt, aber nicht wirklich viel
mehr, viel mehr Details hier rauskriegt.
Ich meine, es sieht oft,
es sieht schon besser aus, ja, kann man nix sagen.
Bist du gesund zu allgemein? Ja,
hatten wir grad schon.
Hat deine Katze auch ein automatisiertes Klo?
Hättest du gerne eine Freundin? Ja und nein.
Ähm, meine
letzten, ähm, das war,
ja, das war nicht so erfolgreich.
Teilweise hat man
das ja auch mitgekriegt.
Es gab ja Zeiten, da war ich echt nicht so gut drauf.
Ich hab ja auch ein paar, paar, paar
Videos in den Zeiten gemacht, ja, also, ja,
ja und nee, ähm,
das Weihnachtsgrill, ja, aber das liegt an mir.
Das ist, das Weihnachtsgrill
ist genau, genau
wieder so das richtige, das richtige
Beispiel dafür.
Ähm, das Problem,
was, was ich da hab, ist, ähm,
dass ich Leute an sich halt
ultraanstrengend
finde und, ähm,
ich
überhaupt keine Motivation
habe, was
zwischenmenschliche Interaktion angeht.
Wenn man versteht,
wie ich, also,
wenn jemand zu mir kommt und sagt,
irgendwas erzählt, dann,
dann red ich mit denen. Ich sag nicht, alter,
piss dich oder so oder hau ab.
Aber, wenn ich mich
um das Fliegen sozialer, ähm,
ähm, Kontakte
kümmern muss, dann mach ich das nicht.
Also, wenn jetzt jemand sagt, ey Max,
äh, wollen wir mal hier XY machen oder so,
dann denk ich mir immer, oh, nee, alter, kein Bock.
Aber mach das dann vielleicht doch.
Aber ich bin jemand, der von sich aus
so gut wie nie auf die Idee kommt zu sagen,
hier, lass uns mal irgendwas machen oder so.
Ähm,
deswegen ist das, deswegen ist das,
äh, nicht so
förderlich, ja.
Man muss halt auch ehrlich sagen, dass diese ganze
Geschichte aus,
sag mal, den ganzen Tag,
oder, sag mal so, Großteil Arbeiten
plus dann halt daheim irgendwelche,
äh, Stream-Geschichten,
YouTube-Geschichten oder irgendwelche anderen
Sachen quasi, äh, so
vor Bildschirm zu machen, dass das schon
in gewisser Weise dazu führt,
dass man weniger
mit anderen Leuten zu tun hat, aber
auf der anderen Seite
ist es, glaube ich, auch so,
dass Leute, die eh schon keinen Bock
haben, oder würde ich mich mal zu zählen, ich hab ja, ich hab
schon öfters gesagt, dass ich eigentlich andere Leute überhaupt nicht mag,
außer Q-Chat ausgenommen,
ähm,
dass die sich gerade solche Beschäftigungen
und Berufe suchen. Also, wenn du jemand bist,
der eh schon keinen Bock auf Leute
hat, dann wirst du dir wahrscheinlich
einen Beruf suchen, der nicht viel mit Leuten zu tun hat,
beziehungsweise
wenn, dann mit halbwegs gleichgesinnten
Leuten, und, äh,
die halt auch sonst
die passenden Hobbys dazu suchen, ja.
Ja, und außerdem kommt
noch dazu, dass das die letzten
Mal überhaupt nicht, äh,
funktioniert hat. Das hat, das hat
nur dafür gesorgt, dass ich ultra
schlecht drauf war, und, äh,
ja, da irgendwie, äh,
ja, weiß nicht, wie soll ich's sagen, ähm,
mir viel zu viel Gedanken
gemacht hab, um, um,
irgendwelche Mädels und, und
Gefühlslagen anderer Leute,
und da krieg, das krieg ich halt nicht gescheit hin.
Anmachsprüche,
da brauchst du ein USB-Kabel,
weiß nicht, ob
das so zieht, ähm,
ich merk das auch,
ich merk das auch immer, dass ich übelst
unmotiviert bin, was sowas
anbelangt.
Wenn, ich mein, es ist
heut eh schwierig, sagen wir mal so, wenn du irgendwie
im Zug sitzt auf dem Heimweg oder so,
äh, die Leute interagieren ja eh schon
relativ wenig. Was ich, wo, wo,
wo viele drüber, drüber rumweinen, so nach
dem Motto, oh nein, das gucken alle nur noch auf ihr Handy
und so, ich find das nicht schlecht,
ich will eh nicht mit den Leuten interagieren,
aber manchmal, ja,
manchmal interagiert man ja doch, was weiß ich,
wenn man in Frankfurt irgendwie rumläuft, sich irgendwas
anguckt, oder wenn man im Zug sitzt, weil,
manchmal interagiert man doch, doch mal irgendwie
mit Leuten, und manchmal,
ähm, hat man auch so das Gefühl,
wenn man mit Leuten, oder wenn man
in dem Fall mit Mädels irgendwie,
ah, zufälligerweise irgendwie ins Gespräch
kommt, dass man sich eigentlich ganz, doch
irgendwie ganz gut versteht, und dass man auch schon
eine gewisse, wie soll man, wie nennt man's
am besten, so, gewisse
Chemie hat, die irgendwie passt, ja,
und dann, ja, wär's ja
eigentlich, also jeder, jeder wahrscheinlich
normale Mensch, würde dann versuchen
irgendwie die Sache, äh, weiter zu
verfolgen, ja, ähm,
in welcher Art und Weise
auch immer, was weiß ich, äh,
ob sie öfters hingeht, oder, oder,
äh, was weiß ich, wie sie das und das
findet, irgendwas, irgendwas in der Richtung, ja,
es geht ja gar nicht so sehr darum, ob's einen wirklich
interessiert, sondern einfach nur,
dass man, dass man ein bisschen Gesprächsstoff hat, irgendwo,
und, ähm,
das Problem
an mir ist, wenn so
nen Fall mal eintritt, dass man
merkt, ey, man, man ist da eigentlich
halbwegs auf, auf einer Wellenlänge,
dann sag ich dann, ah ja, wo, wo war
irgendwie so nach dem Motto, ja, war cool, sich mal
uns zu unterhalten, und dann, dann geh ich heim,
so, steig ich wieder in Zug und verpiss mich.
Ohne irgendwas
probiert zu haben, oder so was,
ich hab da so, mir fehlt da voll
die Motivation zu, was
zwischenmenschliche Interaktion
angeht.
Ich hab voll die Abneigung dagegen, irgendwie mit
Leuten zu interagieren, ne?
Du zwingst deine Freunde immer mal in den Stream zu
gucken, ich weiß nicht, ob das die beste Idee ist.
Ja, übrigens,
der Milchmann hat nen guten, guten Punkt gebracht,
wenn man sich zusammen über die Bahn aufregt,
ihr glaubt gar nicht,
wie sehr die Leute auf einmal, wenn
irgendwas im Zug nicht funktioniert, wie sehr
die Leute auf einmal anfangen,
sich, äh, miteinander zu reden, und
sich zuzustimmen, und sich zu unterhalten, und so,
wenn die Bahn's wieder verkackt, über,
die unterhalten sich dann auch am Anfang über die Bahn,
dann über alles mögliche, aber sobald der Zug
wieder weiterfährt, siehst du so, siehst du
jeden so, ach ja, okay,
geht ja weiter. Handy gucken,
auf einmal instant wieder Ruhe im Zug.
Pavillomania, das,
das mach ich aber auch nicht.
Unternehmst du dann etwas mit Kollegen und Freunden, so ein paar
Feierabendbier, ne, Feierabendbier, ich trink kein Bier,
ähm,
ab und zu, aber, aber nur mit Leuten, wo ich mich echt gut verstehe,
weil, wie gesagt, mit dem Felix war ich ja,
waren wir ja ein paar Mal auf der Gamescom,
das ist ja auch jemand, den ich von der Arbeit kenne, wir haben ja zusammen die Ausbildung
gemacht damals, ähm,
aber zum größten,
zum größten Teil,
ich hab auch nicht so wahnsinnig viele
Freunde irgendwie, ja,
also, wo ich wirklich sagen würd,
Leute, mit denen ich mich lange
Jahre gut verstehe, gibt's eigentlich
nur den Friseur, vielleicht noch ein bisschen den Karsten,
aber mit dem hab ich in letzter Zeit wenig zu tun, ähm,
gibt's eigentlich nur den Fabian.
Ansonsten, gehen mir alle anderen
Leute mega auf den Sack.
Voll die Abneigung, mit Menschen zu interagieren,
interagiert aber gerade mit 300 Menschen, ja,
das ist ja auch hier, ist ja auch,
QChat, ist ja was anderes.
Klickt mal ein paar Mal hintereinander
auf die Schaltfläche neben dem Windows-Logo.
Ist das da? Soll da passieren?
Hä?
Wirklich, fangirls? Nee, nicht wirklich.
Ich hab ein paar weibliche Zuschauer,
das weiß ich, aber ich hab generell wenige hardcore,
hardcore, äh, Fans allgemein.
Ich mein, wozu, find ich, das liegt aber
auch daran, weil die Leute, glaub ich, wissen,
dass ich das bescheuert finde.
Du musst dir einen Hund zulegen, dann reden dich plötzlich alle an,
weil du zutraulicher wichst. Ich will ja gar nicht angesprochen werden.
Ich will mal in Ruhe.
Redi ist ja auch nicht so, dass ich gerne mit Leuten,
es ist ja nicht so, dass ich nicht mit Leuten reden könnte,
aber ich will ja nicht mit Leuten reden.
Wenn ich mit Leuten reden möchte,
dann könnte ich das ja auch irgendwie versuchen,
aber ich will ja gar nicht.
Erlebst du, was, erlebst du auch immer wieder,
dass Leute in Gesprächen mit dir
eigentlich gar nicht wirklich interagieren wollen?
Naja, nachdem ich mit keinem interagiere,
äh, kommt das, oder nachdem ich
bin ja auch jemand, der mit
keinem reden will, ähm,
rede ich eigentlich auch nur mit Leuten,
wo man weiß, dass man,
wo man sich meistens schon kennt
und weiß, dass man eigentlich ganz gut
miteinander labern kann.
Wie ist dein Kontakt zu deinen Eltern
oder Verwandten? Äh, Verwandten
gar nicht. Also ich
weiß gar nicht, wo ich, also
Verwandte nicht wirklich. Äh, Eltern,
meine, wie gesagt, meine Mutter wohnt ja hier.
Das ist ja das Haus,
was wir vom Opa geerbt haben.
Ähm, und
mein Vater wohnt irgendwo in
pff, keine Ahnung,
irgendwie, wie das Kaff heißt.
Aber mit meinem Vater habe ich nicht allzu viel
zu tun.
Es sei denn, er braucht Geld.
Ich weiß, klingt jetzt nach ein bisschen
verkehrter Welt, aber so ist das da bei uns.
Also normalerweise ist es ja
so, dass die Kinder zu ihren Eltern gehen,
wenn sie Geld brauchen. Bei uns ist das umgedreht.
Bei uns ist das umgedreht.
Wenn der Geld braucht, kommt er zu mir.
Ja, stellt so, das ist nice.
Exclusive hatte ich Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Kannst du mal ein paar weibliche
vermitteln? Ich wüsste nicht, wie ich das machen soll.
Wählt dich bei Knuddels an.
Gibt's das noch?
Die Musik ist ein bisschen eintönig.
Ich dachte halt,
ich dachte früher halt, früher hab ich's
ja noch probiert, ne. Früher hab ich's
noch probiert so zu sein, wie ich dachte, dass man
sein muss.
Ähm, das war...
Ich kann euch jetzt leider kein Foto davon
zeigen. Ich hatte so die krasse
Gelschleimfrisur damals, der Wahnsinn, ey.
Naja, ähm...
Und ich hab damals schon immer gemerkt,
irgendwie liegt mir so diese ganze
soziale, zwischenmenschliche Komponente
überhaupt nicht, ja.
Und ich hab damals immer gedacht, das liegt,
das liegt, äh, warum sind
die Leute so komisch und so.
Und irgendwann hab ich dann kapiert, dass die Leute gar nicht komisch
sind, sondern
dass ich irgendwie zu den meisten Leuten einfach nicht
kein Draht hab oder nicht
passe.
Und...
Das ist auch nicht schlimm, aber das braucht
ne Weile, bis man quasi
realisiert, dass das
auch irgendwo dazu
gehört, wenn man halt vielleicht
in manchen Beziehungen nicht so ist,
wie man sich, wie man sich so die Norm vorstellt
oder wie man sich so, so vorstellt,
wie es sein muss. Weil viele Leute
reden sich ja ein, dass sie anders sein
müssten, als sie eigentlich sind,
weil sie denken, dass das irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, gesellschaftlicher
akzeptiert ist oder dass das irgendwie,
äh, äh, die Welt so will
oder so, ne. Aber das dauert ein bisschen,
aber irgendwann kommt man mal da drauf, eigentlich hat
das überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Wenn man, wenn man das versucht,
so zu machen,
wie man denkt, ist,
dass es sein müsste, ohne dass man das selbst will.
Nudels gibt's noch,
tatsächlich.
Kann dir Grindr empfehlen
als Dating-App?
Ich dachte, das ist überhaupt nicht mehr im,
im Trend, dass man, dass man quasi,
äh, die Sachen mit R, so Fiverr,
Twitter, äh,
Flickr,
dachte, das ist überhaupt nicht mehr im Trend. Tinder,
ich dachte überhaupt nicht, dass diese mit R hinten dran ist, gar nicht mehr im Trend,
so.
Wir haben heute übrigens noch gar nichts gemacht,
was wir normalerweise im Aufwach-Stream machen, ne.
Witz.
Okay,
was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten hier?
Using worst
classes in Black Ops 1.
Ach nee, was ich angucken wollte, ist das hier.
Das habe ich nämlich heute Morgen gesehen,
Kona, ähm,
das habe ich heute Morgen nämlich bei mir auf dem
Tablet gesehen, das ist ein
ehemaliger Microsoft-Mitarbeiter,
der sich darüber auslässt,
warum Windows 10 so viele Bugs hat.
Das wollte ich mir mal angucken, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Äh, mal gucken, ob das, ob da was dran ist.
Funktionieren tut es ja nicht, wenn es viele Bugs hat.
Warum hast du eine englische Tastatur?
Habe ich nicht.
Ich habe eine englische Sprache
und eine deutsche Tastatur.
Willst du was trinken gehen?
Ich glaube auch, ich bin der einzige,
der in der IT arbeitet, der keinen Kaffee trinkt.
Wir haben uns, wir haben ja kostenlosen
Kaffee, Kaffee, so Kaffee-Ding-Ding-Ding.
Das ist ja kein Kaffee-Automat, das sind so
so fette Maschinen, die irgendwie acht verschiedene
Sorten Kaffee machen können, von Espresso zu
normalem Kaffee zu irgendwelchem
Latte-Zeugs und so.
Und das kostet bei uns ja nichts und dementsprechend ist
vor diesen Kaffee-Automaten, das ist bei uns immer übertrieben
voll und
ähm,
ich laufe da immer so vorbei, um ab und zu für meinen Tee
ähm, die Tasse zu holen
und da denken sie alle schon, ich will an den Kaffee-Automat.
Da sage ich, ne Leute, bleibt, bleibt stehen, den Kaffee trink ich gar nicht.
Weiß, ich weiß nicht, warum, also
warum alle so auf Kaffee stehen, kann ich nicht verstehen.
Tee, größer
Kaffee, ja.
Kommt eine Switch ab und zu noch zum Einsatz?
Ja.
Jetzt wieder.
Ich habe mir jetzt Dings gekauft,
hier, äh, Links Awakening
für die Switch. Die Musik ist zu laut.
Ja, das ist mal wieder, weil sich der,
weil die sich nicht entscheiden
können, wie laut ihre unterschiedliche Musik sein
will. Ich gehe auch
nicht in irgendwelche Geschäfte, fällt mir gerade einer.
Das einzige, wo ich manchmal in Geschäfte gehe, ist, wenn
ich mein Lebensmittel kaufen muss, aber ansonsten
alles,
alles online kaufen.
Ich glaube, die
meiste Interaktion
zwischen, zwischenmenschliche Interaktion,
die nicht mit Leuten auf der Arbeit
ist, hatte ich mit meinem DHL und
Hermes-Zusteller.
In den letzten Jahren.
Du kaufst Tee online, ja?
Ja.
Weil hier, ah,
da kaufe ich Tee.
Was sich übelst eklig anhört,
aber gut schmeckt, ist,
ähm,
Gott, ah, das gibt's nicht mehr.
Hier,
kaufe ich mal. Himmlische Zitrone,
ah, das ist nice. Davon habe ich, davon
habe ich ein paar Packen.
Also, ich habe schon ein paar Packen gekauft, die sind echt nice.
Das finde ich bei uns gut, äh,
Fly Booster.
Bei uns ist es auf der Arbeit nicht so.
Also,
zumindest mit den Leuten, wo ich da
zusammenarbeite. Konkurrenz
gibt's in dieser Form bei uns nicht.
Wir machen uns eher
gemeinsam über, über, äh,
andere Entwicklungen lustig.
Hast du mal Matcha getrunken?
Du meinst dieses grüne japanische Zeug,
ja? Geht so.
Nicht mein Fall.
Ist ja
mittlerweile relativ im Trend.
Gibt's jetzt ja auch mittlerweile Eissorten damit und
solche anderen
Drinks und so, wo die das reinmachen. Ich finde das nicht.
Nicht so gut.
Früchtetee.
Wo ist dann das, was ich aktuell trinke?
Ich glaube, das gibt's.
Lemon Twist ist auch nice.
Okay.
Alle trinken.
Ich,
ja.
Das schmeckt auch gut.
Türkischer Apfel-Traum ist auch nice.
Süßer Drachenweiß.
Übertreiben sie es aber mit den Namen, oder?
Sanddorn, ich kenn bloß Sandstorm.
Äh, naja, gut.
Ähm, wir gucken uns das jetzt im Video an.
Max, kannst du mal
OBS-Einstellung erklären?
Was denn genau?
Trinkst du Energydrinks?
Ne.
Was das angeht, bin ich eigentlich
relativ, leb ich eigentlich relativ gesund.
Dafür ist das restliche Leben
nicht sonderlich gesund.
Also ich trink keine, keine
irgendwie Fanta, Cola, sonstwas.
Äh, kein Kaffee.
Keine Energydrinks.
Ähm, trink eigentlich nur was,
Wasser und Tee.
Dafür ist das andere nicht sonderlich gesund, ja.
Gut, ich rauche auch nicht, ich trinke nix.
Also wenig.
Sehr wenig.
So eins, zweimal im Jahr was.
Ähm, ja, natürlich
vertrage auch überhaupt nix mehr.
Rauchen tu ich auch nicht.
Das einzige, was ich halt mache, ist,
ich sitz zu viel vorm Rechner.
OBS zum Streamen, ja, zum Streamen ist das das Beste,
was du machen kannst.
Zum Aufnehmen find ich Shadowplay eigentlich recht angenehm.
Shisha Bar, Max.
Das ist ne Sache, ganz ehrlich,
die würde ich sogar mal ausprobieren.
Aber, das Problem ist,
wenn ich, wenn ich da,
gibt's ja bei uns ein paar, wenn ich da reingucke,
ja, in diese Bars,
die's bei uns da in Frankfurt im Bahnhof sind,
wenn ich da reingucke und sehe,
was da für Leute sowohl da vorstehen, als auch da drinnen sitzen,
da frag ich mich, äh,
keine Ahnung,
ob das noch Frankfurt ist,
ja.
Da geh ich nicht rein.
Ich glaube, da hab ich mich, als ich, ähm,
wo wir, wo wir
in der Türkei im Urlaub waren, ich glaube, da hab ich mich
irgendwo in der türkischen Innenstadt
heimischer gefühlt, als im
Shisha-Laden im Frankfurt-Bahnhofsviertel.
Warst du mal im IH-Pub
beim Bahnhof? Nee.
Aber ich weiß, wo du meinst.
Das ist direkt, äh, direkt an der Treppe,
wo du, wo du,
quasi unten durchlaufen kannst vom Bahnhof.
Läuft Shadowplay mittlerweile
ohne GeForce Experience World? Nein, leider nicht.
Gehst du an die
Talschen? Ja, das, das kann schon sein.
Ich geh da ja gar nicht hin. Das kann schon sein.
Ich kenn nur die, wo ich vorbeilaufe,
bei uns Frankfurt im Bahnhofsviertel,
und die sehen nicht so aus, als will ich da rein.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ja, und GeForce Experience ist
der letzte Scheiß. So, gucken wir uns mal an,
was er da zu sagen. Äh, warum
hat Windows 10 so viele Bugs?
Erzählt uns
ein Ex-Microsoft-Mitarbeiter.
Dann. Gucken wir mal.
Ein 8K!
What the fuck?
Ich, ich wollte ihn, ich wollte ihn mir schon immer
in 8K angucken.
2K.
Kein Unterschied.
1440p.
Auch kein Unterschied. Ich seh da keinen Unterschied.
1440p reicht.
Okay.
Also, hören wir uns das mal an, was er sagt.
Passt Lautstärke?
Denk schon.
15 Jahre Microsoft.
Okay.
drucken, der ist egal
ob mein Chef, der kann das an der Stelle auch nicht entscheiden
das ist ja was übergreifendes
das ist richtig cool, die Idee gefällt mir
vielleicht mach ich das auch einfach
selbst, für die Sachen wo
ich quasi für zuständig bin
machen wir
jede, keine Ahnung, jede
zehnte Version
jede zehnte Version
druck ich aus meinem 3D Drucker
irgendwas aus für die Handvoll der Leute
die quasi maßgeblich
dran beteiligt waren
können sich das hinstellen
nächste ist Version 70, wir sind grad bei 66
nächste ist Version 70
da druck ich irgendwas
mit meinem 3D Drucker aus oder so
ich find das ist ne richtig coole Idee
mit dieser Shippet Plakette
und das ist eine von meinen Shirts, head on over to shop.barnerd.com
this is by far the most famous shirt I've ever created
and yes, Microsoft still watching
this is a nod to the privacy issues
with the operating system, which I've made many other videos on
which I will link down in the video description
and as a matter of fact, I'm just getting ready to reinstall
Houston PC right there, that's my Puget Systems build
I'm getting ready to install it with 1903
even though there's a ton of known issues with the upgrade
to the operating system
installing in place uncompatible hardware
you're not gonna hit as many of them, so
that's what we're hoping for
alright, well let's start up
ahja, ist ja gut
ey, ich muss grad mal was gucken
hab ich eigentlich schon das neueste Update drauf?
oh, das war jetzt keine so gute Idee, oder?
wo sieht man denn, was man installiert hat?
wo sieht man seine Windows Version überhaupt?
winfair
okay
zu Windows User
ist das das aktuelle?
oder gibt es schon
19, keine Ahnung
1910 oder so
was ist denn das neueste? 1910 Windows?
oder was kommt denn als nächstes? 1911?
19... was?
1909 müsste doch schon längst draußen sein
ah, fertig, hier
es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass 1909 im November kommt
das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn
wenn es im November kommt, müsste das 1911 heißen
nein, das Insider-Programm kommt
die kriegen noch nicht mal ihre eigenen Namenssachen hin
die kriegen sie nicht
das ist so wie Windows
Windows wurde in den letzten Jahren getestet
ich spreche von vor dem Layoffs
im late 2014, early 2015
es gab ein gesamtes Testteam bei Microsoft
das sich nur um das System des Operators beteiligt hat
das Team wurde in vielen Sub-Teams geteilt
die sich als Branchen oder Build Labs repräsentieren
und dann kommen sie alle zusammen in einen täglichen Konsens
durch viele automatische Tests
tägliches Meeting, das heißt sie haben 3 Stunden am Tag gelabert
wenn das drei größere Teams waren
to determine whether or not they got to share the code upstream through the pond
and eventually it would enter into this pool called WinMain,
which was basically everybody's code smashed together
from all the different disciplines of the operating system,
like UI, networking, inbox applications, drivers, display stuff, kernel, HAL, etc., etc., etc.
Now these meetings were critical because it allowed everybody to come to the table as human beings
and discuss why they needed to hold back code from making it into the RTM bits,
which would ultimately ship to...
Was heißt denn RTM nochmal?
Ready to... to manufacture? Ready to...
Radio Televisum Malaysia, ja.
Ready to manufacture?
Ready...
Ready to market? Ready to market, ja.
Ready to...
Manufacture, ja, beides, beides.
Okay, dann erzähl...
Erzähl uns mal, warum es so viele Bugs gibt in Windows.
...to the world.
That's...
RTM stands for Release to Media.
Basically, they're burning CD...
Release to Media?
Ernsthaft?
Das hab ich noch nie gehört.
Okay, das benutzt außer ihm auch keiner.
Release to Media.
Vor allem, welche Media?
Downloads.
...to sell to you at that point.
Or actually download now, because who uses optical media?
Actually, I'm gonna be installing from optical media when I do my next video.
Make sure you subscribe, by the way, and ring that bell,
if you like this content.
Alright, well, these gates come together,
and everybody basically has a say
in representing what bugs are found in the operating system.
And these are bugs that are found on real hardware.
We're talking about automated tests that are run in a lab
that literally has like a thousand individual computers
that represent all of the hardware diversity,
or as much of it as there is humanly possible
with what is out there on the market.
They had computers with AMD graphics cards,
NVIDIA graphics cards, integrated graphics,
they had AMD CPUs, Intel CPUs,
even a lot of the little oddball stuff.
And they even had a mobile lab
where they tested on laptops.
And they still do to some extent today.
But here's the problem.
They laid off the entire Windows test team
with a few minor exceptions
and basically replaced it with the team
that was testing Windows Phone.
Okay, das ist natürlich eine ziemlich bescheidene Idee.
Du schmeißt die Tester raus, die sich damit auskennen,
und lässt Windows Phone Leute jetzt Windows testen.
Big brain.
The reason the layoffs occurred is because
three different divisions at Microsoft
that were like sub-companies,
Xbox, Windows Phone, and Windows,
were all merged together under one house
because they all had to play together.
They got sick of having three basically
independent pieces of software
and they wanted them all to share
the same architecture basically.
Now I personally thought that was a great idea
and I think it's amazing that our Xbox One console
now shares the same exact kernel
that we have on our PCs.
And if Windows Phone was still around today,
it also would be running the Windows 10 kernel,
which I believe it...
Was witzig ist zur Xbox-Entwicklung,
wie gesagt, ich habe selbst nie was für die Xbox entwickelt,
aber ich habe letztens...
Letztens war es drüber gelesen und zwar,
dass zwar auf der Xbox
mittlerweile mehr oder weniger
ein abgespecktes Windows läuft,
allerdings laufen noch
quasi zwei Frameworks
oder mehr oder weniger zwei
ähnlich Betriebssysteme,
zwei, zwei, ja, also so basic Sachen
auf der Xbox parallel
und diese ganzen Windows-Geschichten
verwendet auf der Xbox kaum einer.
Die verwenden alle,
ich glaube,
oh, wie hieß das?
Ära und Game...
Fuck, ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
Nicht Gamecube, äh, Game...
Gamecore?
Kann das sein?
Das muss wohl irgendwas...
Letztens gelesen, das muss wohl irgendwie
was Paralleles geben auf der Xbox
zu diesem Standard-Windows-Kram,
den wohl auf der Xbox
viele Entwickler gar nicht verwenden,
obwohl er da ist.
Deswegen gibt es auch so wenig UWP-Spiele,
aber es sind ungefähr 100% der Leute.
Also wie...
Ja gut.
Ein Betriebssystem testen auf VMs
ist irgendwie
das Gegenteil von Big Brain.
Das ist quasi, äh,
Three Head.
Das ist Small Brain.
Also ein Betriebssystem auf,
nur auf VMs testen,
klingt irgendwie
nicht so clever.
...
Das ist natürlich eine clevere Idee.
Man lässt die Leute auf ihrem Arbeitsplatzrechner
DevBuilds benutzen,
dass die sich darüber auskotzen bei den Entwicklern,
wenn ihr DevBuild nicht richtig funktioniert.
Das finde ich gar nicht schlecht, ehrlich gesagt.
Umso mehr Leute,
die den Kram täglich benutzen und Feedback geben,
umso besser.
...
Das Problem ist, dass die meisten von den Bugs, die sich erzeugen, nicht etwas zerstören, sondern eher etwas, das nicht richtig funktioniert.
Wenn etwas nicht richtig funktioniert, dann generiert es keine Informationen, die in Form eines Dumpf-Files an Microsoft gehen müssen,
die sie dann laden können und dann sagen können, oh, hier ist mein verdammter Code, der alles zerbrochen hat.
Aber anstattdessen bedienen sie sich auf einen User, der das berücksichtigt.
Und die Wahrheit ist, dass viele der Windows-Insider diese Probleme nicht berücksichtigen,
ohne dass sie zu ihnen katastrophal sind, was bedeutet, dass nur ein kleiner Teil der Menschen, die das Problem beheben, es tatsächlich berücksichtigen.
Und selbst wenn sie es berücksichtigen, können sie Microsoft nicht geben, was sie erzeugen müssen,
damit sie herausfinden können, wo der Bug ist und wie sie ihn lösen können.
Und das ist natürlich das Problem, wenn man sich das mit dem Anzugucken anschaut,
als irgendein Typ, der, keine Ahnung, in Bangladesch sitzt, einen Windows-Notebook hat und da ein Insider-Bild drauflaufen hat.
Das funktioniert natürlich irgendwo nicht so gut.
Und außerdem, wenn eine Anwendung nicht crasht, dann gibt es auch keinen Dump.
Klingt auch logisch.
Weil du hast unter Windows so viele Sachen, die einfach nicht richtig tun,
wie zum Beispiel diese komische Suche da, die teilweise einfach aufhört zu suchen und sowas,
das sollte dann nicht passieren.
Es gibt auch solche Bugs, wo der Crash außerhalb des Prozesses passiert,
Fall und Punkt.
Sagen wir, du hast ein Stück Software und es bricht auf.
Aber der Grund, warum es brach auf, war wegen einer externen Abhängigkeit,
dass etwas falsch war.
Also sagen wir mal, ein Service auf dem Computer.
Nun, wenn dieser Prozess zerstört, im Grunde genommen,
ohne dass du all diese Sachen während der Installation ausführen kannst,
wird es ein Dump-File nehmen, das ist ein kleiner Memory-Snapshot.
Und ich sollte sagen, ein Mini-Dump, nicht ein voller Dump.
Es ist wie ein kleiner Dump.
Nicht ein großer.
Im Grunde genommen sendet es ihnen nur die sehr, sehr relevanten Informationen
genau dort, wo dieser Prozess brach und nur innerhalb dieses Prozesses.
Ein voller Dump würde einen Memory-Snapshot des gesamten Computers nehmen,
damit sie alle Abhängigkeiten zwischen diesem Prozess und...
Du kannst ja auch keinen kompletten Memory-Dump ziehen von irgendeinem User.
Soll der da irgendwie seine 8, 16 GB RAM hochladen mit allem möglichen drinne?
Würde einen Teufel tun, meinen kompletten RAM-Inhalt zu Microsoft hochzuladen.
... externe Prozesse auf Sachen im Operationssystem zu laden
und herauszufinden, wo das echte Problem ist.
Diese volle Dump werden selten, wenn auch nie, auf Microsoft veröffentlicht,
weil sie nicht auf Microsoft veröffentlicht werden.
Sie sind absolut riesig.
Das bedeutet, wenn Microsoft einen Mini-Dump hat,
müssen sie versuchen, effektiv den Bug in den Wänden von Microsoft zu erzeugen
und ihn wieder zu reproduzieren.
Und das ist das, woran...
Gibt's dafür nicht RP-Traces?
Ja, das... so wie ich ihn verstanden hab, meint er das damit.
Diese Sachen werden zu Microsoft hochgeladen,
allerdings haben sie oftmals das Problem, dass sie die Abhängigkeiten,
beziehungsweise die Sachen, wie das entstanden ist...
Sie sehen zwar den Fehler, können den Fehler nachvollziehen,
aber sie wissen... sie kennen die Voraussetzungen nicht genau,
wie der entstanden ist.
Das ist anscheinend so das Problem, wenn ich ihn richtig verstehe.
...team used to come and in 2015 as we would reproduce these bugs,
set them up, hook them up with the developer
and give the developer everything that they needed
so that they could look at the full context or the full picture of what was going on
and correct the issue.
Now, unfortunately, today the Microsoft developers have to depend on basically...
Telemetry.
They basically have to look at a bug database in...
Prime 99... äh, 1996, 90, abonniert auf Stufe 1.
Ein richtiges Abo.
Mit dem Namen hätte ich aber eigentlich einen...
Prime!
Samus Climber!
Da hätte ich eigentlich einen Prime-Sub erwartet mit dem Namen
und keinen richtigen Sub, aber dankeschön für zwei Monate in Folge.
Samus Climber!
N-n-nice!
...and see where the majority of the crashes are happening
and look at what little bit of information the computers send about those crashes
to try to figure out what actually happened.
And then when they fix the bug,
they don't really have a good test bed internally to make sure it's 100% fixed,
so there it goes into the insider builds, it gets pumped out to customers again,
and then by and large they judge whether it's...
Äh...
Äh, Evoli sagt grad, wäre das nicht ein großes Datenschutzproblem,
wenn die den ganzen RAM auslesen könnten.
Äh, kommt drauf an.
Also ich denke, wenn man das nur in Insider Builds machen würde
und auch nur mit, äh, quasi...
nicht, dass Microsoft Remote den ganzen RAM auslesen kann,
sondern dass quasi im Fehlerreport
der jeweilige, der das reporten will, sagen muss,
ja, ich möchte jetzt meinen kompletten RAM-Inhalt dumpen und attachen,
wär doch okay.
...if it's fixed or not,
whether it created new issues,
which is, again, hard to determine, right,
how do you connect issue one with issue two,
unless they are clearly connected,
or the issue just stops reporting after a number of insiders start updating the build.
Now, what used to happen when a major update came out for the operating system
is they would push it out to everybody,
but we saw that this was really, really bad about a year or two ago,
when they released an update that bricked like,
I don't know, about a quarter of the world.
Maybe that's a little bit of an exaggeration,
but it was a lot of people and it caused a lot of stir in the press.
With the, with the, with the, with the, uh, with the SSDs, right,
or with the USB-Stacks, I don't know, they had an update,
that totally messed up a lot of stuff,
like, a year ago or so.
So now they shifted gears and they do, uh, basically rollouts and waves.
This is why sometimes you open Windows Update and you'll notice
you may not have 1903 available to update to,
or your computer may even say that your hardware has been determined
not to be ready for it just yet.
And that's basically Microsoft's way of telling you that
we are not quite sure if this is gonna run right on your hardware
based on the telemetry that we got back from the Insider.
Hmm.
So now Microsoft has taken an approach of basically once the Insider builds...
Habt ihr euch nicht auch schon mal gewundert?
Das, das ergibt Sinn.
Habt ihr euch nicht auch schon mal gewundert,
warum überall steht so nach dem Motto,
neues Windows Update ist raus,
aber ihr bekommt's nicht als Update angeboten?
Das ist, das hab ich mir auch schon öfters gemacht.
Ich mein, guck mal, angeblich, angeblich ist doch auch, ähm,
angeblich ist doch 1909 irgendwie,
nee, noch gar nicht, ist nicht, stimmt nicht, Blödsinn.
Äh, aber das letzte Update hatte ich das auch.
Das war raus in Windows Update.
Ich hab's irgendwie erst einen Monat später gekriegt oder so.
Und dann hab ich gesehen, wie die Telemetrie zurückkommt,
wie die Bugs zurückkommen.
Und dann, als sie sich stärker und stärker aufmerksam machen,
gehen sie zum nächsten Schritt
und rollen es an mehr und mehr Leute.
Das Problem ist,
das initiale Set von Leuten, die sie wählen,
sind im Grunde Dogfooding das Software
und sie könnten auch Windows Insider selbst sein.
Denn Microsoft hat keine hohe Aufmerksamkeit in diesem Software.
Andererseits würden sie es einfach an alle ausrollen,
genau wie sie es mit Updates vor 2016 gemacht haben.
Nun, ich empfehle Microsoft,
dass sie erkennen, dass es ein Problem mit ihrem Testsystem gibt.
Und sie nehmen jetzt Baby-Stücke und rollen das Software raus.
Aber das ändert nicht,
wie viele Leute mich täglich anmerken
und mir sagen, dass ihre Box kaputt ist
oder der Netzwerkspreis kaputt ist
oder sie können nicht mehr nach einem Update
ihre Geräte aufmerksam machen
oder ihr Hardware einfach einfach aufhört zu arbeiten.
Das sind Probleme, die vorher gefunden werden würden.
Sie würden von dem Testsystem gefunden werden,
das bei Microsoft war,
die im Grunde die Gatekeepers waren.
Und das ist eigentlich, was sie uns genannt haben.
Und ich hoffe wirklich,
dass jemand von Microsoft dieses Video
auf einem hohen Niveau von Microsoft schaut und sagt,
weißt du was?
Vielleicht ist dieser blöde Kerl im YouTube-Video richtig.
Vielleicht ist er richtig.
Vielleicht sollten wir das Testsystem wieder hinstellen.
Nun, du wirst nicht die gleichen Leute bekommen,
wie ich das bekomme.
Und die Chancen sind...
Ob du in einem halben Jahr was machst
oder ob du quasi irgendwie vier Jahre Zeit hast.
Dass sie da in Richtung Testautomatisierung
oder das optimieren wollen, kann ich verstehen.
Aber ob der Weisheitsletzterschluss ist,
dass du quasi es nicht mehr auf Hardware testest
beziehungsweise es nicht mehr von Leuten testen lässt,
die Ahnung haben von dem, was sie testen,
das ist fraglich.
Es gibt kein neues Windows mehr, davon mal abgesehen.
So.
OS as a Service.
Ja, ich weiß nicht,
ob es für Betriebssysteme so eine gute Idee ist.
Aber übrigens, ich denke schon,
dass es ein neues Windows geben wird.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube nicht,
dass Microsoft ewig Windows 10 herstellen wird.
Es wird mit Sicherheit ein neues Windows geben irgendwann.
I'm probably not gonna return.
But you could get a team together that would train up...
Ansonsten könntest du dir einfach die Versionsnummer auch sparen.
...just like it.
You can bring the old UI automation back online.
You can run more automated scenarios.
You can run on more diverse hardware
and stop trying to run millions and millions of test passes
on virtual machines
to find bugs that happen 100% of the time
and instead switch over to actually using kind of half and half
with the real hardware.
Oh, hab ich den Sampler gesehen?
I think that that would greatly increase your ability
to catch these bugs before they're going out to customers.
Und most importantly,
if you guys are seeing a ton...
Zahnphysik...
...
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Ganz ehrlich, Leute,
bin ich übrigens eh der Meinung,
wer Insider-Builds laufen hat
und wirklich Insider-Builds laufen hat,
um Fehler zu reporten,
und er reportet wirklich einen Fehler,
also was Wichtiges,
jetzt nicht irgendwie
ein Pixel ist grün statt blau,
wobei das auch auf größere Probleme hindeuten kann.
Mal genommen, jemand führt wirklich
Insider-Builds auf, untersucht das nach Fehler,
macht im Prinzip den Job für Microsoft,
findet einen Bug und reicht den ein
und er sorgt dafür, dass quasi
der Bug nicht mehr...
Das sollte wirklich einen Reward kriegen.
Zumindest irgendwas
Symbolisches auf jeden Fall.
Ja?
Ich meine,
eigentlich sollte es auch was
Besseres kriegen, ja?
Warum machen die nicht irgendein
Bugfinder-Programm, so was weiß ich.
Bei 5 Bugs kriegst du eine Xbox,
bei 10 Bugs
kriegst du, keine Ahnung, einen Surface.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass es
viele Leute gibt, die 10 wichtige Bugs finden
oder so. Warum nicht?
Microsoft hat das Geld.
Und es ist immer noch billiger, als
ein komplett neues eigenes Test-Team wieder hinzustellen.
Ein gratis
Windows Phone zum Beispiel.
Haha, was kein Mensch mehr braucht.
Ja?
Das wär doch cool.
Bei 50 kriegst du irgendwie eine Plakette oder so.
Warum nicht?
Das wär doch wirklich ganz cool.
... way for that.
Because you don't have internal testers
and you get what you pay for.
And if you're not showing people that you're gonna reward them
for reporting these bugs
and uploading these critical full dumps,
a lot of these bugs are gonna go unfixed
and your developers are gonna do something that's even worse.
And this is something that even happens sometimes
when I was working for the company.
And that is, they're gonna guess what the problem is.
They're gonna go change code that is completely unrelated
to the actual bug because they don't understand it fully.
Or they're gonna introduce a new bug
or a new performance hit to the system.
And that's the last thing we need.
I figured it was high time that I made this video
since I'm getting ready to install 1903,
which is actually a pretty good build.
It's not always fun to reinstall and set it up for free
and it works for all of us.
And before I end this video and everything...
Okay, das Video ist fertig.
Äh, ich muss sagen, er hat echt gute Punkte gebracht, ja.
Klingt, klingt einleuchtend.
Ja, Azure, Azure-Guthaben könnten sie auch verteilen.
Zum Beispiel fällt mir noch ein,
ich muss noch 80 oder 90 Euro Azure-Guthaben irgendwie ausgeben,
weil das demnächst verfällt.
Service Game, Apokalypse,
ah, nee, das ist eine Gamestar-Talkshow.
Eigentlich nicht.
Drei Stunden.
Leute, sind wir wach?
Das Gamestar-Video ist nice.
Warum überhaupt neue OS und nicht konstant
an dem aktuellen Arbeiten abhängen?
Machen sie doch, machen sie doch.
Aber ich denke mal,
dass die auch aus marketingtechnischen Gründen
irgendwann mal Windows 10 rausbringen.
Und es gibt bestimmt
die ein oder anderen Umbauten,
die wahrscheinlich ein bisschen länger dauern als, äh,
quasi von einem Jahr,
also von einem halben Jahr aufs nächste halbe Jahr.
Du willst ja auch mal was rausschmeißen irgendwann.
Okay, da gucken wir uns mal das Gamestar-Video an.
Laufen die Server von Microsoft eigentlich auf Windows?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wir können, wir können mal gucken, ob das, ob das der Fall ist.
Wahrscheinlich.
Gucken wir mal, wir gucken mal.
Also mir fällt jetzt da nix Gescheites ein, außer der, ähm,
Nmap-Test.
Der Nmap-Test, was das für ein Server ist.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie was, was bringt.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Ging das nochmal Nmap?
Nmap, äh, OS-Detection
minus O, okay.
Gucken wir mal, ob der das erkennt.
Nmap minus O, gucken wir mal, ob er bei mir erkennt,
dass es Linux ist.
Ja, ist gut.
OS-Details, Linux, okay.
Ähm, okay, also testen wir.
Microsoft.com.
Okay, die mögen nicht, die mögen schon mal nicht,
Nmap gescannt zu werden.
Nicht Freeze meine, vor allem mal.
Gucken wir mal, ob das, ob Nmap irgendwas erkennt,
was, was Microsoft, äh, für ein Betriebssystem hat.
No host matched, okay, ja.
Ja, okay, wir kriegen das anscheinend nicht raus,
unter was das läuft.
Überleg grad, steht in irgendwelchen HTTP-Headern drinne,
was das für ein Webserver ist?
Normalerweise nicht.
Habt ihr eine andere, glorreiche Idee,
wie man das rauskriegen könnte?
Also, mir fällt jetzt da nix, nix eins ein.
E-Mail schreiben, genau.
Okay, was sagt die, was sagt die Gamestar zu Service Games?
In den letzten zwölf Monaten sind drei große westliche Publisher
mit ihren Service Games gescheitert, zumindest was die inhaltliche,
die Qualität anging.
Gibt's das überhaupt noch?
Fallout.
Los ging's mit Fallout 76 von Bethesda,
dann kam von EA Anthem,
und jetzt das jüngste Beispiel ist von Ubisoft,
Ghost Recon Breakpoint.
Eins schlechter als das andere.
Aber warum sind diese Service Games gescheitert?
Da ist ja, da ist ja Ghost Recon noch das Beste.
Scheitert, was ist das verbindende Element?
Das frag ich jetzt meinen Kollegen Dimitri Hallay.
Hallo, Dimi.
Hi, Fritz.
Woran sind diese Spiele gescheitert?
Gibt es überhaupt so etwas wie ein verbindendes,
verdammendes Element, wollt ich sagen,
ein verbindendes Element?
Es gibt ein verbindendes Element.
Und wenn man es sich sehr leicht machen will,
kann man sagen, alle drei sind daran gescheitert,
dass sie zum Release einfach keine sehr guten Spiele waren
und die Leute das nicht angenommen haben.
Die spannende Frage ist halt, warum waren es keine guten Spiele?
Und alle drei ...
Weil es keine Spiele sind,
die wirklich mit Überzeugung und Idee entwickelt wurden,
sondern einfach nur Spiele,
die eine gewisse Checkliste abgehakt haben und versucht haben,
das einzubauen, was andere Spiele erfolgreich machen.
Und das ist das, was mich sehr gut gemacht hat.
All diese drei Spiele haben versucht,
das, was die Marken, für die sie stehen, eigentlich ausmacht,
im Fall von Anthem halt Bioware-Rollenspiel,
im Fall von Fallout halt Fallout
und im Fall von Ghost Recon, Ghost Recon, Taktik-Shooter, Open World,
das halt zu verheiraten mit einem funktionierenden Service-Game,
also einem Service, eine Art Spiel,
die du über lange, lange Zeit jeden Abend spielst,
wo du dich immer wieder einloggst, wo du permanent neuen Content bekommst.
Und diese, sag ich mal, Spiele, die du immer wieder einloggst, wo du permanent neuen Content bekommst,
und diese, sag ich mal, Spiele, die du immer wieder einloggst, wo du permanent neuen Content bekommst,
sagen wir mal, Hochzeit von diesen Dingen,
hat einfach bei keinem dieser Spiele funktioniert.
Warum nicht?
Weil es tatsächlich schwieriger ist,
so etwas funktionierend zu implementieren,
als man vielleicht denkt.
Also Ghost Recon Breakpoint ist ein sehr bildliches Beispiel dafür,
weil sie eben versucht haben,
das, was Wildlands cool gemacht hat in den Augen der Fans,
einfach irgendwie zu kombinieren mit einer Loot-Spirale.
Weil irgendwie mussten die Leute ja langfristig bei der Stange halten.
Und da gibt es halt unterschiedliche Konzepte.
Bei Multiplayer-Spielen logischerweise neue Maps, neue Charaktere,
neue Waffen, die Art neuer Inhalte, das ist bei Multiplayern so.
Bei Singleplayer-Spielen ist es ein bisschen schwieriger.
Da wird es im Moment halt sehr gemacht über Loot-Anreize,
über irgendwie neue Quests, Raids,
aber vor allem halt über Beutemechaniken,
über Rollenspielmechaniken oder irgendwelche Progressionsmechaniken.
Also wahrscheinlich sollten wir eher Koop-Spiele sagen,
weil das Verbindendelement von diesen Spielen ist ja,
dass sie sehr auf Koop ausgelegt waren.
Genau, aber halt eher PvE,
also eher Kampagnen-fokussiert und nicht so sehr PvP-fokussiert.
Weil der Vorteil nur bei Multiplayer-Spielen,
bei PvP-Spielen ist,
die Leute spielen gegeneinander und das ist etwas,
da entsteht sehr schnell eine langlebige Dynamik,
wenn die Maps und die Waffen und so weiter gut gemacht sind.
Bei PvE-Spielen musst du dir als Entwickler,
ich will nicht sagen, mehr Mühe geben,
weil Multiplayer-Spiele generell schwer zu machen sind,
aber du brauchst halt neuen Content,
du musst immer neuen Content nachreichen.
Und daran ...
Da ist ja überhaupt nichts dagegen zu sagen.
Es ist ja eigentlich cool,
wenn Spiele lange Zeit mit neuem Content versorgt werden.
Das Spiel muss bloß was taugen.
Und der Content muss Content sein, den die Leute haben wollen.
Das funktioniert bei MMOs schon seit 10 Jahren, seit 15 Jahren.
Aber die Spiele müssen halt was taugen.
Man kann sich einfach ein Spiel nach der Checkliste hinklatschen
und dann ab und zu mal eine neue Map veröffentlichen.
Also daran sind die Spiele nicht gescheitert,
weil so weit ist es ja gar nicht groß gekommen bei Anthem,
sondern an der Auslegung, dass ein Spiel darauf ausgelegt ist,
irgendwie von vornherein immer neuen Content zu bekommen,
aber das Release-Paket darunter gelitten hat,
das ist das, woran es dann halt gescheitert ist.
Warum wollen denn alle so ein Service-Game jetzt machen?
Weil's ein extrem lukrativer Markt ist.
Geld? Was sonst?
Die letzten Jahre sieht man ja schon,
in Zeiten der digitalen Vermarktung
probieren Publisher sehr viele Dinge aus.
Und Service-Games sind ja von der Grundidee weniger toxisch
als jetzt beispielsweise Vermarktungsmodelle,
die sehr stark mit konkreten Bezahlmethoden verbunden sind.
Der hat noch nie Overwatch-Rank gespielt.
Oder zu viele DLCs.
Ein Service-Game ist ja vorgelagert
erst mal das Versprechen eines Entwicklers,
dass ein Spiel, das du gut findest,
immer wieder mit neuen Inhalten versorgt wird.
Und das ist ja was, da würden wahrscheinlich die meisten Spieler sagen,
ja, ist cool, gibt's ja auch seit vielen Jahren.
Diablo ist so ein Fall, Rainbow Six ist so ein Fall.
Diverse Service-Games, die super gut funktionieren.
Das ist was, glaube ich, wo Spieler, Publisher, Hersteller
und so sich einig werden können.
Und da ist man ja erst mal dankbar für,
dass man halt als Publisher irgendwie was gefunden hat,
wo die Leute sagen, nehmen wir an.
Und das lässt sich aber natürlich auch sehr gut
mit Monetarisierungsmethoden kombinieren.
Da haben wir über die Jahre jetzt sehr viel gesehen,
ja, den klassischen Season Pass,
einen Jahrespass wie bei Rainbow Six.
Es gibt Mikrotransaktionen, irgendwelche Kosmetikshops.
Hör auf mit Season Pass.
Es gab die Ära der Lootboxen,
die damit irgendwie versucht wurden zu kombinieren.
Und jetzt jüngst gibt es halt diese Fortnite-Battlepass-Mechaniken,
dass du halt Season Pass und Jahrespass
und kosmetische Sachen miteinander kombinierst.
Bei Fortnite klappt das verhältnismäßig gut,
muss man mal sagen.
Bei Apex müssen wir jetzt mal gucken,
ob die da noch die Kurve kriegen, aber bei Fortnite klappt das gut.
In Fortnite packen die wirklich einfach
jede noch so beknackte Idee, die irgendein Entwickler hatte,
bauen sie einfach mal ein.
Gucken, wie das funktioniert und dann und tschüss.
Also Fortnite, man kann von dem Game halten, was man will.
In dieser Richtung machen die das echt nicht verkehrt.
Add-on-Varianten und so weiter.
Also da gibt es halt einen sehr großen Markt
für Arten, was zu monetarisieren.
Und das ist, wenn es funktioniert, halt eine sehr gute Geldquelle,
weil du natürlich irgendwie ein GTA,
das vor sechs Jahren oder so wurde halt Los Santos ...
Okay, der ist cool, der Typ, der sagt GTA.
Daran erkennt man die coolen Leute.
Der sagt bestimmt auch Ubuntu.
Das ist das erste Mal veröffentlicht,
GTA V auf der alten Konsolengeneration noch.
Seitdem versorgen sie ja GTA Online mit neuen Inhalten.
Und das ist natürlich weniger aufwendig,
als jedes Jahr, wie ein Assassin's Creed das gemacht hat,
eine komplett neue Open World zu bauen.
Also viel, viel weniger aufwendig.
Ein Ghost Recon Breakpoint oder so,
da sind über 1000 Leute daran beschäftigt,
diese Open World drei Jahre lang zu bauen.
Wohingegen du einen neuen Content biet,
irgendwie eine neue Map, zwei neue Operator,
das kannst du mit viel, viel weniger Leuten umsetzen,
verdienst aber in dieser Jahrespassmechanik
ähnlich viel Geld damit.
Wahrscheinlich sogar noch mehr Geld damit, ja.
Super, dass du's grade gesagt hast,
weil GTA, find ich, ist so ein bisschen,
steht wie so ein Leuchtturm in dieser Branche,
wo zudem alle hinfahren wollen.
Manche mit so viel Vollgas,
dass sie halt einfach mal auf die Küste aufschlagen und zerschellen.
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass das Game, als es rausgekommen ist, schon gut war.
Also mein Fall ist es nicht.
Also GTA, den Witcher ausgenommen, der geht noch.
Aber GTA war halt auch schon das,
was die Fans erwartet haben zu Release
und nicht irgendwie so ein unfertiger Klotz.
Und außerdem, was bei GTA noch dazu kommt,
ist diese ganze Roleplay-Geschichte.
Ich bin nicht der große GTA-Spieler.
Ich kann dieser ganzen Roleplay-Geschichte
auch nicht so viel abgewinnen,
aber ich kann's nachvollziehen, warum das so viele gucken.
Daran ist GTA tatsächlich so dieses Ding,
was dafür gesorgt hat,
dass wir jetzt den Gedanken Servicegame
auch verbal so ausgesprochen haben von vielen Publishern.
Weil es wird ja jetzt so betont, du hast es gerade schon gesagt,
Servicegames gab es, diese Grundidee gab es eigentlich schon immer.
Spiele wurden früher über Abos bei WoW weiterentwickelt und so.
Aber jetzt wird ja dieser Begriff
auch so oft in den Mittelpunkt gestellt.
Und ausgerechnet bei den Spielen, wo dieser Begriff so fokussiert ist,
das sind auch oft die Titel,
die dann aber eben genau mit diesem Service versagen.
Ja, und das ist eigentlich eine Ironie.
Aber tatsächlich war es ja bei GTA Online gar nicht so,
dass Rockstar von vornherein mit der Art Erfolg gerechnet hat.
Deswegen ist ja auch GTA Online von der ganzen Server-Architektur
so furchtbar veraltet, die Ladezeiten sind furchtbar lang.
Das war eigentlich ursprünglich,
das war so ein netter Zusatz dieser Multiplayer-Geschichte.
Die ganze Menüführung ist kompliziert,
die Ladezeiten wurden weiter erweitern mussten.
Haben sie auch selbst kommuniziert,
weil sie nicht damit gerechnet haben,
dass das Ding so durch die Decke geht.
Das heißt, bei vielen funktionierenden Servicegames
ist das Label Servicegame weniger wichtig.
Und du merkst, die Idee war eigentlich,
wie können wir ein möglichst geiles Spiel machen.
Und ohne jetzt irgendjemandem was zu unterstellen zu wollen,
aber du merkst eben schon gerade,
also gerade bei einem Publisher wie Ubisoft,
ist eher so eine Konzernstrategie,
jedes Spiel, das wir machen, soll ein funktionierendes Servicegame sein.
Ja, genau das ist das Problem.
Rockstar wollte ein gutes GTA machen.
Und wenn du dir die Anthem anguckst,
die wollten kein gutes was.
Die wussten bei Anthem ja noch nicht mal,
was sie genau eigentlich machen wollten.
Sie wussten eigentlich nur,
wir wollen ein Game haben,
womit man gut Kohle machen kann.
Und dann haben sie eine Checkliste erstellt,
so nach dem Motto, wir brauchen das, das, das und das.
Ja, check, check, check, check, haben wir.
Ein gutes Gesamtgame kommt da halt nicht bei raus.
... reinschreibt, das kann schwierig sein.
Und bei Ghost Dream Breakpoint ist es eben so.
Du kannst das nicht machen,
du kannst nicht einfach sagen,
wir machen aus allem ein Servicegame,
nehmen das, was früher ganz cool war,
kombinieren das irgendwie mit dem, was jetzt neu ist,
was halt Servicegame-loot-mäßig funktioniert.
Und das wird dann ein super Paket, das die Leute annehmen.
Du brauchst immer noch ein Spiel,
das halt in den Kerntugenden funktioniert.
Richtig, deswegen ist Raid Wars 6 taugt auch.
Vielleicht ein interessantes Story hat,
ein interessantes Gegnerdesign, ein interessantes Missionsdesign,
ein interessantes Open-World-Design.
Ein The Witcher 3 bleibt halt nach wie vor
das beste Beispiel für eine funktionierende Open-World,
weil halt da alles funktioniert.
Weil all diese Faktoren super gut funktioniert haben
und nicht, weil das Ding halt permanent
neuen Content bekommen hat.
Also erstmal braucht man ein gutes Spiel,
wo man ein gutes Servicegame daraus vielleicht machen kann.
Eigentlich ein No-Brainer, ja.
Sollte man meinen, aber dieser Begriff Servicegame,
würdest du sagen, der ist verbrannt?
Ich glaube, in der Wahrnehmung der Spieler,
die sich wirklich damit beschäftigen, ja schon.
Also man muss ja immer mitbedenken,
die Leute, die überhaupt wissen, dass Servicegame
der Name ist für die Art Spiel, sind nicht unbedingt
der breite Mainstream.
Das ist einfach so, sehr viele Leute
kaufen sich Jahr um Jahr ihr Fifa, ohne jetzt irgendwie
ein Gespür dafür zu haben, dass sie
quasi in jedes Jahr einen Service einkaufen.
Gibt ja sogar Leute,
also das ist ja der größte
der größte Skamars-Laden
überhaupt, Fifa.
Gibt ja sogar Leute, die bezahlen Kohle dafür,
dass sie früher Kohle ausgeben dürfen.
So nach dem Motto
Early Access Transfermarkt,
dass ich bezahle Geld, dass ich Geld ausgeben darf.
Also ey,
das kann ich echt nicht verstehen.
Für den sie jedes Jahr
irgendwie 60, 70 Euro ausgeben und so.
Aber ich glaube, innerhalb der
sagen wir mal passionierteren
Gaming Community ist
Servicegame mittlerweile
ein eher verpönter Begriff.
Natürlich, weil man irgendwie auch sagt,
ja die Leute, die von vornherein ein supergeiles
Angebot haben, müssen ja nicht
die ganze Zeit versprechen, ja da kommt
noch Service, da wird es kostenlos neue Inhalte
geben, wir bringen euch nach Release noch
neue Maps und neue Helden und so weiter.
Das ist ja prinzipiell auch eine coole Sache, nur
ich glaube, es gab jetzt einfach zu viele
Spiele, die das zu
sehr in den Vordergrund bei der Vermarktung
gesetzt haben und wo es aber dann nicht funktioniert hat.
So nach dem Motto, Spiel kommt raus,
enthält aber überhaupt nichts, aber man kriegt
versprochen, oh, es kommt noch ganz viel
geiles Zeug. Ja was bringt es dir denn, wenn
das Spiel von Anfang an suckt?
Muss man einfach sagen bei Ghost Recon Breakpoint,
dieser Ingame-Shop wäre wahrscheinlich
weniger ins Gewicht gefallen, wenn das Spiel
halt richtig, richtig gut gewesen wäre.
Weil theoretisch kannst du den ja ignorieren,
der ist eigentlich rein kosmetisch,
er ist nicht ganz rein kosmetisch, man kann auch
Waffen kaufen, aber man kann es ja alles im Spiel freischalten.
Warum klassisches Glücksspiel wieder auf Twitch
und YouTube zurzeit beliebt ist, kann ich,
verstehe ich auch nicht.
Kann man beiseite schieben, theoretisch.
Klassisches Glücksspiel ist eigentlich sowas aus
dem letzten Jahrtausend. Nur dadurch, dass
das Spiel sich halt so leer, so hollow,
so seelenlos teilweise anfühlt,
kommen die Leute und sagen,
ja, aber der Shop, ja, und das ist einfach
nur um Geld zu machen und so weiter und so fort,
ich kann das schon nachvollziehen. Der Shop ist da, aber eure Inhalte
sind nicht, wir müssen ja nicht mal
zu Breakpoint gehen, Anthem zum Beispiel
ist ja auch ein perfektes Beispiel. Da wurde im allerersten
Werbevideo, wurde dieser
Cataclysm-Event
groß angedeutet und dann kam der
Monate nach dem Release, ist jetzt so eine halbe
Nummer und das Spiel ist längst tot. Also
Armed Service Games ist einfach auch das
übertrieben mit der Hoffnung der Spieler zu
spielen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und man muss
ja bei Anthem und Fallout 76 sagen, das sind ja
noch nicht mal Spiele, die jetzt aggressiv
irgendwelche Ingame-Shops vermarkten oder so,
dass man sagen kann, die wurden in erster Linie für
Transaktionen gebaut.
Sie wurden in erster Linie gebaut, um
eine Plattform zu schaffen, wo man
so etwas vielleicht implementieren kann, ja.
Aber sie sind halt schon vorher gescheitert.
Fallout 76
zu sagen, wir machen einen Multiplayer-Fallout,
wo ihr über Jahre und Jahre und Freunde das da machen könnt,
dann kommt das raus, ist verbuggt,
hat sehr viele der Stärken, die Fallout
ausgemacht haben, nicht mehr, ist stattdessen so
einfach eigentlich nur so ein Crafting-Ding
mit so ein paar Story-Titbits und so.
Da sind die Leute eben enttäuscht.
Und je häufiger sie enttäuscht werden,
desto weniger wollen sie
oder desto weniger assoziieren sie
mit Service-Game irgendwas Positives.
Ja, also man kann es dann mit der Hoffnung
auch übertreiben. Sprechen wir mal über einen anderen
Bereich Hoffnung. Gibt es irgendwie
Licht am Horizont, dass
es eine gewisse Gegenbewegung
gegen diese Service-Game-Idee
gibt? Jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt den guten
Teil der Service-Game-Idee, nämlich erstmal ein starkes
Spiel zu machen und dann das
noch zu verbessern, zu erweitern,
sondern wirklich zu sagen, aus
der mehr oder weniger Geschäftsleitung
der Abteilung kommt die Idee, wir machen jetzt
ein Service-Game, weil damit verdienen
wir lange Geld. Gibt es irgendwie einen Trend,
wo du sagst, da gibt es Hoffnung, dass das
vielleicht sich wieder ein bisschen
einpegelt mit dem Markt? Das sind ja immer
Hoch- und Runterbewegungen. Ja, da gibt es im Prinzip
zwei Trends, würde ich sagen. Das erste,
worüber man reden kann, ist
diese Art von, dass
Publisher halt bestimmte Dinge ausprobieren,
wo halt viel Geld liegt,
und damit gegen die Wand fahren. Das ist eine Wellenbewegung,
die sehen wir halt seit Jahren.
Das jüngste Beispiel sind halt die Lootboxen.
Lootboxen wurden plötzlich entdeckt als, wow,
damit kann man voll viel...
Selbst wenn jetzt irgendwo erzählt wird, es gibt keine
Lootboxen mehr, und da groß... Mittlerweile ist es
ja so, dass man weniger
Marketing drum macht, dass das eigentliche Spiel
gut wird, sondern so nach dem Motto, keine
Microtransactions, kein Battle Pass,
keine Lootboxen, bla bla bla,
und unter der Haube... Ich meine,
weißt du, wenn man nicht
die Vorteile des Spiels in den Vordergrund
stellt, sondern verkauft, dass man
keine Nachteile hat, ist schon irgendwie beknackt.
Dazu kommt,
dass die Dinger natürlich doch so
oder so irgendwie im Game drin sind, und einfach
nur anders heißen.
Viel Geld machen, das funktioniert... Das ist so wie
Fuck You, Last Stand damals. Last Stand war nicht
im Game, aber Final Stand war genau das gleiche.
Voll gut. Dann hatten es
plötzlich alle Spiele, und EA
hat dann gesagt, ja, wir wollen jetzt in jedem Spiel
von uns, ähnlich wie bei FIFA und
Madden und Co. halt dieses Ultimate Team drin
haben, die Lootboxen und so weiter. Boah, hör mal auf, so ein
Kuschel. Dann kam Star Wars Battlefront, und dann kamen noch ein paar andere Spiele,
die komplett damit auf die Nase gefallen sind, und
jetzt verschwinden Lootboxen, und es kommen
neue Systeme. Also,
auch da die Kritik der Spieler
kann da sehr viel bewegen, und ich würde
auch behaupten, nach Fallout 76,
nach Anthem, nach Ghostfreaking Breakpoint
werden sich alle drei Publisher, Großpublisher
überlegen, ob sie die Art
Spiel in der Schärfe von
Servicegames... Nö, nö. Sie wissen
jetzt ja, dass es auf diese Art und Weise nicht funktioniert.
Entweder schmeißt man die Entwickler raus,
das, was ja auch mal
ganz gern gemacht wird, oder man macht einfach das
Gleiche wieder, nur mit leichten Variationen, bis es
funktioniert. Weil, die
werden garantiert nicht von einmal ins Klo
gegriffen aufhören,
zu versuchen,
mehr Kohle zu machen. Das wäre ja auch komplett
scheuer anzunehmen.
Game-Marotte nochmal machen.
Also, man kann
zumindest damit rechnen, dass es da Anpassungen geben
wird, die sich vielleicht irgendwann auf einem Level einpendeln,
wo man sagt, das ist eine bessere,
gesündere Harmonie zwischen
langlebigem Content und
klassischem Spiel. Das
zum einen. Und zum anderen ist ja
eigentlich das nächste große Finanzierungsmodell schon am
Horizont zu sehen, nämlich die Abo-Modelle.
Das war ja auch bei der diesjährigen E3 so,
aber da muss man auch kein Hellseher sein.
Mittlerweile brauche ich 50 Abos.
Origin, Access, Premiere,
Uplay Plus,
der Microsoft Game Pass
und so. Und da
ändern sich Dinge schon, weil
für einen Microsoft Game Pass ist
nicht so relevant, dass
du jetzt dieses eine Spiel hast, das eine Destiny
oder so hast, wo du jeden Tag
einloggst, sondern es funktioniert eher über
die Netflix-Mechaniken, das Angebot
das du da bekommst,
kostenlos für deine monatliche Abo-Gebühr.
Das muss
halt super sein.
Da kann es auch zum Beispiel sein, dass man sagt,
okay, wir haben neben einem Gears 5
halt noch irgendwie das neue
Singleplayer-Rollenspiel von Obsidian,
wir haben in Kingdom Come Deliverance da drin,
wir haben dieses 7 Stunden super
coole Kampagnen-Spiel für die Leute, die Singleplayer
lieben. Unser Angebot ist
vielfältig, es ist breit, es ist für die
Leute was, die ein Spiel jeden Abend spielen wollen,
es ist für die Leute was, die am Wochenende immer gerne
ein Spiel durchspielen wollen.
Das wird halt wichtiger sein.
Publisher nehmen dann eben Geld in die Hand und gehen zu,
also im Fall von Microsoft, gehen sie halt
zu den Spieleentwicklern und sagen, wir geben euch so und so viel Geld,
dafür bieten wir euer Spiel exklusiv
bei uns im Microsoft Game Pass an
und dann gucken wir, ob die Leute das halt annehmen.
Also ich will natürlich nicht sagen,
dass die Game Pass-Modelle
jetzt resistent dagegen sind,
irgendwie gegen die Wand gefahren zu werden
oder dass sie jetzt Service Games verschwinden
lassen oder so, aber sie bergen
doch durchaus das Potenzial, dass sich der Markt
dadurch noch mal drastisch ändert,
wenn sich das durchsetzt.
Ja, dann werden wir uns das mal im Auge behalten,
die Game Passes sind ja tatsächlich aktuell
wirklich super spannend, gerade der Xbox Game Pass,
wo man ja wahnsinns Angebote nach dem Vielfeld bekommt.
Das stimmt, das ist wirklich nicht übel.
Also wenn man gerne Xbox spielt, ist das tatsächlich nicht schlecht.
Schauen wir mal, wie die Branche im Großen und Ganzen
dann darauf reagieren wird.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das neue Gears für 1,99 gespielt.
Und wie sich die Service Games in den nächsten
Jahren weiterentwickeln werden, gerade von diesen
drei großen Publishern,
die damit jetzt so auf die Nase gefallen sind,
die dann ausgezogen werden, wird sicherlich für
so was wie Dragon Age 4 zum Beispiel
sehr, sehr spannend werden, wie das aussehen wird.
Moment, was? Dragon Age 4?
Haben sie das nicht schon zu Tode geritten?
Dragon Age, der erste,
das erste Dragon Age war richtig geil,
alles andere danach war einfach nur Crap.
Ich drück mal die Daumen in
ein Wildlands 2, weil
da liegt mir doch ein bisschen am Herzen,
kann ich nicht drum rum reden.
Dimi, vielen Dank für die Einschätzung,
vielen Dank für die auch ein bisschen das
Hoffnung geben, dass da doch wieder mehr Vielfalt
reinkommen kann.
Nice. Leute, jetzt die große Preisfrage,
sind wir schon wach?
Max, was ist
das Meme Board?
Na das hier, wo ich so meine
meine Bildchen
overlayen kann.
Sind nicht wach. Gut, dann gucken wir uns
jetzt noch ein Black Ops 1 Video von
Fortunate an und dann
muss ich aufs Klo.
Weil wir haben bisher jeden Sonntag
mindestens ein Video von Fortunate geguckt,
den müssen wir dieses Jahr auch mal wieder gucken.
Dieses Jahr, also diesen Sonntag
auch mal wieder gucken.
Today we are going to be using the worst
possible classes in Black Ops 1.
Now unfortunately Black Ops 1 doesn't have a
nuke, which means we can't use terrible
classes to get nukes in this game, but
I guess what we could do is we could go for dogs
Nein, nein, das stimmt nicht
mit den 500.000 Spielern.
Nein, nein, das ist bug, das stimmt nicht.
Das sind, wenn's hoch kommt, 1000 Spieler oder so.
Das ist verbuggt, die Anzeige.
Anyways, using these classes
is going to be absolutely brutal. I have some
crazy stuff lined up here.
Enjoy the video. And if you're looking to try G Fuel,
use code FORTUNATE for 10% off at checkout.
Let's get right into this.
This is the first class we're gonna be starting with here.
Uzi with ACOG.
I'm using decoy grenades.
I got a jammer. Uzi in this game
really, really sucks.
I got him!
Und die Armbrust war cool.
Let's go.
Die Armbrust war nice.
I got him too? Oh my gosh.
Also ernsthaft, spielen mit der Armbrust konntest du nicht, aber
den hatte schon irgendwie was.
Jeez, Luis.
Run, run, run.
Game's awfully quiet right now.
Die Waffe hat tatsächlich gesagt,
die habe ich nie gespielt.
Oh no, I didn't know he was back there.
Well, I guess my biggest goal
is to probably just win these games, right?
I mean, I'm using these terrible, terrible
classes.
Here we go.
Wow.
Oh, I got a headshot.
Oh no.
Why does it have to come at me?
Sorry.
Oh, oh, oh.
What? Von wo?
Da liegt er!
So he has a claymore and he's just sitting there too.
Alter, die Leute.
This kid, he actually just won't move.
I guess I just have to hipfire with this, huh?
What makes it so bad?
This damn sight.
This RCXD is coming for me, but it can't get up here, can it?
Alright, I'm gonna put this down on the floor.
Try and get a killstreak.
He snuck up behind me, too.
Got him, too.
This jammer sounds crazy.
Er ist host, oder? Ist er host?
Ich weiß nicht, ob er host ist.
Oh, not that guy. He's just sitting in the back.
Ich glaub nicht, dass er host ist.
Doch, der könnte.
Doch, doch, er ist, glaub ich, host von dem Game.
I should take, like, a spray at this guy.
I literally started right here.
That's my first bullet, I think.
Huge spray.
And I went all the way up there.
Why would anyone ever use this gun?
I don't understand that.
Why even make a gun this bad?
They destroyed your equipment.
Oh, vorbei.
Back here, he's back here.
Er ist definitiv host.
When you aim down sight with this thing,
it's seriously so bad.
I'm not even gonna get the 30 kills.
Oh, normalerweise out er immer krass in den Videos.
Aber es kommt bestimmt noch.
Die Waffe ist wirklich kacke.
Alter, die Waffe.
Die Waffe ist so schlecht.
Oh my gosh, did you see my weapon spray on that?
The bullet spread? Geez.
Close call.
That's really embarrassing.
Oh, come on.
He's running to it.
He actually ran to my radar.
He ran to the ping on the radar.
That's funny.
Why are people sitting in corners?
Weil Leute gerne campen.
Weil das sonst für ihr Hirn zu viel ist,
sich zu bewegen.
Könntest du mal ein Mikrotik Video
das Film machen?
Jetzt werden sie umgesprayt.
Will I get 3 more kills in 10 seconds?
Oh.
I mean, I did win.
7 und 62, okay, das ist jetzt...
Mit der Waffe.
Verständlich, ja.
For me, it's pretty awful.
Anyways, we're gonna use another gun here.
Our second class, the RPK
with thermal.
Oh my god.
Destroy all enemies.
Oh, so eine Kackwaffe.
Es ist besser, wenn er mit der Pistole spielt,
als mit dieser Kackwaffe.
I'm dead serious, it might be hard to win a game.
Ja, du Scheiße.
Wow.
Enemy spy plane incoming.
Da war übrigens gerade ein Gegner neben ihm, oder?
War da nicht gerade ein Gegner neben ihm?
Oh.
Wartet mal.
Da!
Wolltest du doch sagen, ich habe einen Gegner gesehen.
Plane incoming.
Was ist mit dem Typ los?
Was ist mit dem Gegner neben ihm los?
I don't know, I guess with thermal it feels wild.
Oh, I have flakjack on anyway.
What do I care?
Let's go.
Enemy RCXD spotted.
Damn, the guy in first is actually killing it right now.
I gotta step up my game.
Wie viele Spieler spielen das noch hier,
diesen MW2-Mod,
den ihr gerade im Chat gepostet habt?
180.
That was me trying to single-shot the RPK, actually.
Okay, actually.
Okay, das Game hat übrigens ordentliche Pistolen, ne?
Die Pistolen zum größten Teil,
also diese kleinen Pistolen
in Modern Warfare,
die waren richtig schlecht.
How did he know where I was?
Turned and instantly
started spraying.
Die Waffe ist so schlecht, ihre Art.
I gotta win this game, to be honest.
Enemy spy plane incoming.
Guck dir das mal an, was eine Kackwaffe.
Dude, dude, dude, dude.
That guy's still over there?
Well, I guess he's just always on that side of the map.
You know, I heard someone.
Alter, was Kackwaffe.
Das tut ja schon weh beim Zugucken.
I had it your way.
At least I'm catching up a little bit.
Spy plane standing by.
Not good that one of these guys got killstreaks.
That plane's killing everything.
I think he's still in this building.
That's where you are.
Oh my gosh.
Spy plane's ready for deployment.
Friendly spy plane inbound.
Honor campers almost ruined my life.
Wisst ihr, ich würd auch lieber mit ner Pistole spielen,
als mit dieser Kackwaffe.
I'm the best.
Blackbird, Blackbird, fehlt nicht mal viel.
Fehlt nicht mal viel.
He really just ran back here to, like, sit here?
I don't, who does that?
That was the same guy
who just got destroyed.
Our SR-71 is in the air.
I'll just take this.
Actually, I forget if you could hack care packages
so I'm not even gonna take it.
I wanna get my dogs.
Here we go.
Let's go, we got towers.
Heads up, enemy RCXD spotted.
Let's go.
Oops.
I think they kinda, like, kills pretty quickly.
Enemy spy plane incoming.
I'm on a nice killstreak.
Enemy spy plane above.
I only need two more kills.
I gotta finish the game.
One more kill.
Spray and pray. Got him, let's go.
Thirty and seven.
4.29 KD, that was a lot better than the last game.
The win sound is really nice.
I don't even think I've ever seen a class like this.
This has to be the worst class ever.
Was spielt der denn überhaupt?
Was ist das? Was ist das überhaupt für ne Waffe?
If I win this game, that's pretty incredible.
It has, like, a very slow fire rate.
But the recoil isn't bad, so I get kind of
single shot like it's a FAL.
Nee, das ist keine Fall.
In the corner, doing what?
SVD? Ja, die SVD ist das, genau.
Thank gosh. I don't even know how I'm on the streak right now.
Oh god, that was close.
Come on, come on, do it, do it, do it, do it.
Enemy spy plane above.
Der stirbt jetzt ordentlich. Knapp, knapp, knapp.
Just run, just run.
Upgraded sights, but it doesn't look upgraded at all.
GD2-Hitter-Teil.
F-R-71 ready for deployment.
F-R-71 in the air.
I'm gonna be the man. He saw me. He definitely saw me.
Oh god, it's not good.
Chase this guy down.
I'll just go for this dude.
Lag. No! Why are you lagging like that?
Oh, das ist fies.
Das ist fies, ey.
This guy over here ready?
Enemy spy plane above.
He lived for old time's sake.
Woah, it's so cool how it just rattles back and forth.
Can I kill one of them in here?
I just want one kill in here, come on.
Enemy spy plane incoming.
Oh, wait, wait, wait. Turn around.
Bin eigentlich nie in diese Gondel reingegangen.
Why are you camping like that, bro?
Oh, he wants to win.
Badly.
There we go.
I'm gonna reload this real quick.
I'm only...
Oh, weggesprayt.
Mit dem Ghost-Typ weggesprayt.
Wow, buddy.
Whatever, man.
Wow, I really don't understand this.
Nice hipfire.
I'm pretty close to winning.
Spy plane ready for deployment.
Show yourself.
He's got the akimbo shotguns.
He was mid dolphin dive.
Haha.
How did all my bullets just miss him?
That made absolutely no sense.
Come on, buddy, you're one shot.
There we go.
What? One shot, one kill? No way.
Is it weird that I don't remember this Black Ops 1 music towards the end?
I really don't remember hearing this music ever in Black Ops 1.
Come on, look this way.
I know you're strapped, buddy.
I didn't know this thing gets one shot kills.
There we go.
30 and 15 should have done a lot better.
Nice.
Yeah, there was some weird stuff in Black Ops 1 that I never played.
Oh.
So, guys.
I'm awake.
I'm awake, guys.
I'm going to go to the bathroom.
I'm going to go and eat.
And...
I have to record something.
So, guys.
See you.
Until then...
Is the hairdresser on?
Is the hairdresser on, maybe, that we can host?
Wen können wir hosten?
Ich guck mal kurz bei denen, denen ich folge.
Äh...
Keiner da.
Okay, also, Leute. Macht's gut.
Bis denn. See you.